Experience.
Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by nine all day.
That's it.
It's up.
All right.
This is the first ever HD
version of this podcast.
Burned stand.
You are the guest.
Wow.
Damn it.
You're the perfect guy for this first
ever first ever use stream HD version of
the podcast and a,
as it's gotten here,
I just got a a an email while I'm on.
Victor contains a email list and you know,
Victor Conte,
Depaul Co guy,
the guy who was suspended for getting
all those guys on some undetectable
steroids and now he's some sort of a
crusader against a performance enhancing
drugs.
And he just sent me this thing.
John Jones,
testosterone levels are suspect
and it's saying that he's probably,
he was probably on steroids coming off.
The biggest winner was UFC career.
A few would have expected Jon Jones
to have the worst week of his life.
Blah,
blah blah.
And drug test cocaine is the big one
that everybody's been talking about.
Uh,
but the thing about the
epic testosterone levels,
that's what they're saying.
The mean it.
Conte has a,
you know,
a bunch of numbers and ratios and
what's normal and what's not normal.
But apparently this is a,
this is an issue now to the
people are talking about.
Yeah.
You know it's interesting Kevin,
I oli was tweeting some stuff about that
yesterday and you know when you take a
look at,
at some of the things that are taking
place as well is there are some major
flaws in the collection.
Whoever was the sample collector and I
don't think the commission just wants to
out them whoever did that because
the first test was supposed to be for
performance enhancements and then
it was actually recreational.
It was never supposed to happen like that.
So then when they tested him two weeks
later after failing a recreational,
then they test them for
performance enhancing.
And I guess that's probably where
they got his testosterone ratio.
So you know when,
when they get back his
post fight drug test that,
I mean this,
this will be real interesting,
but when I talked to friends
of mine that I had at Usada,
I texted with them today and,
and you saw a is as good as it gets.
I mean these guys don't miss that
stands for the U S Anti Doping Agency.
Yeah.
The federally,
the Federal Government backed
organization that does the Olympics and,
and they told me strip,
they said,
look,
yeah there's,
there's definitely some indicators there,
but they're,
they,
they believe at right now it looks like
there's some flaws in the collection.
So who knows how this thing could
possibly hold up an arbitration and if,
if that collection process had
anything to do with the flood levels,
there's a lot of details
yet to be uncovered.
So when the collection levels what
it's supposed to be supposed to be,
one guy,
there's a chain of custody,
he administered the test,
takes the blood and like handcuffs
it to his fucking cha wrist,
right?
Like,
like one of those nuclear
bombs and like the,
the nuclear football thing.
And they take it and
it's supposed to be like,
this guy has it.
He signs off on and he sleeps with it.
He doesn't go anywhere with it until
it gets to that lab and then from there
it's they have a direct chain of custody.
Exactly right.
And the big key there,
there,
there's a few areas
where it can be flawed.
One,
the collector,
if the collectors not fully trained in,
in,
you know where,
then the second part is
what lab do they send it to?
You know,
I did confirm today Nevada had that urine
sample sent to the wattle laboratory
in Salt Lake City,
which is a,
is is one of the best and one
of the two best in the country.
You know,
you get salt lake and then you have UCLA.
Those are the labs that can
detect all the high level stuff.
However,
it was still a urine sample and urine is
a lot less accurate than a blood test.
When you,
when you're talking about
looking at testosterone levels,
et cetera.
Yeah.
And water is the world anti-doping agent.
Exactly like that.
They're the ones who make the
regulations at the Nevada state athletic
commission and everybody
else follows when they say,
Hey,
what's your protocol?
Or what standards do you follow for
performance testing drugs or are banned
substances?
Well,
we followed the Wada Code and so you saw
it a uses that same laboratory as well.
Um,
you know,
but,
but the difference
there is the collectors,
the organization and,
and,
and they're,
you know,
they're,
they're the premier
organization in the world,
probably a,
and they do it worldwide.
For folks who don't know
what we're talking about,
Jon Jones,
who's The UFC light heavyweight champion,
number one pound for pound fighter,
pretty much consensus in the world.
One is biggest fight of his
career against Daniel Cormier,
but then tested positive
for cocaine metabolites,
which means that,
uh,
the,
the test is administered on December 4th,
which means some tea sometime between
two and four days before that he had done
cocaine.
Yeah,
it's,
do you hear that Wine Jamie?
It's the fan as it come
through the microphone.
I can't tell.
Okay.
Oh,
that's not good.
The fan for that.
Yeah.
Is it coming through your microphone then?
Shut your microphone off.
Yeah,
that's it.
Yeah.
You're going to have to turn
your microphone on and off.
What?
We're going to have to
put that thing somewhere.
No.
Yeah.
Well either way.
We're cool.
Um,
so for folks that don't follow the UFC,
this was a huge fight.
Probably one of the biggest
fights ever as far as skill level.
I think probably one of
the biggest fights ever.
Cause you got the number one pound for
pound fighter in the world and a guy who
many people thought could beat him.
Yup.
And,
uh,
John Wound up winning
the fight and winning,
um,
in pretty impressive fashion
because he beat him wrestling.
He took Daniel down first time
ever in Daniel Daniel Cormier,
he was an Olympic wrestler,
undefeated as a heavyweight.
Anissa light heavyweight was a
real threat and John beat them.
So now that the cocaine was one thing,
but then this,
the testosterone to
Epictetus testosterone ratio,
which seems to indicate that
something else going on,
that's a way bigger deal.
It is.
And,
and you know,
right now there's a ton of speculation.
Um,
if,
if the,
if the ratios were were bigger,
I think we'd hear a lot more
talk about it right now.
You know,
right now people say,
hey,
these could be indicators to
something masking steroids and,
and again,
this all just developed.
So I certainly don't think either one of
us had had a whole lot of time to dive
into the details.
So,
you know,
you,
you got to hope that this scenario
doesn't get any worse at this point.
You know,
you really don't.
I,
you know,
personally having trained at that
gym for a number of years now,
I haven't been down there in
years since even before I retired.
Um,
but there were never any rumors
about John doing stuff like that.
I mean,
from day one when he came into the gym,
he knew nothing and he still kicked
everybody's ass bad to the point where
people were just jealous,
uh,
to the point where people thought,
okay,
you know,
there's no way he wins this fight.
Now they finally match Migas
Guy who's going to beat him.
Then you watch him fight and he just
smokes guy mean we wondered how he was
going to do against Brandon Vera.
Do you remember that fight?
I mean he made it look like a
joke and he did it to everybody.
I mean all the way through,
you know,
on other than the Gustafson
fight and then obviously,
you know,
or even the Rashad Evans fight,
the Rashad Evans fight,
you know,
it was,
it was a dominant victory,
but it wasn't something where he just,
he ran through it.
So I personally never heard any
rumors in any inside the fight circle.
You generally hear a lot,
you know,
a lot of guys do a lot of talk
and when it comes to that stuff,
but uh,
you just never know,
you know?
Well that was one of the
reasons why you retired,
right?
You,
you were having a real issue with the,
the level of performance enhancing drugs.
Like the permeation of it.
Yeah,
yeah.
In the sport.
Absolutely.
You know,
you see it when you
train in these gyms and,
and so you'll see guys that you come in
and all of a sudden their physique looks
totally different and you
can feel the difference.
And so it's interesting because when you
mentioned that a bunch of people throw
out excuses,
et cetera,
et cetera.
Look,
I need to mention this until six months
after I retired and I was in a position
where,
hey,
you know what,
maybe I can influence the sport a little
bit here and try and steer in the right
direction.
But it's a major,
major advantage when someone
goes on that type of stuff.
And you know,
for me,
I had to fight at a different weight
class that I already thought was fishy
about that as well.
You know,
Vince Vandelay Silva,
hey,
you're going to fight it light heavy
instead a middleweight in the middle
weight.
You know,
those things happen.
And I still signed to do the
fight even with my suspicions.
But if you're going to go at it clean and,
and you're going to lose the guys that
maybe you suspect we're doing something,
you know,
for me it came down to decision 0.1.
Am I willing to go back to a major camp
and train and leave my family behind for
weeks at a time?
No.
Am I willing to level the playing
field and take something like that,
compromise my integrity.
Um,
you know,
to,
to be better and get back
on an ascending climb my,
my career.
No.
Well then I'm out.
I'm out.
It wasn't worth the head
trauma at that point.
So the Vandelay Silva fight,
why was it light heavy weight
as he went on to find it?
He wanted it.
Well he's,
you know,
he's got issues of his own,
of course.
Vandelay Silva who was an all time great.
I mean an absolute pride,
a long time pride,
what they call a middleweight champion,
which was 203 pounds and pride,
which is light heavyweight in the
UFC and most likely juice to the,
I mean,
let's be,
let's be honest about it.
I mean,
everybody in pride was there.
There was a lot of people in
pride doing a lot of crazy shit.
Uh,
you know,
you talked to ensign anyway
in the ensign anyway,
said that they,
they literally had a clause
in the contract in pride
saying that they would not
test you for steroids.
Yeah.
And you know,
that's,
you know,
this,
this has been a subject that for me,
you know,
especially in the last year,
it's one of those subjects
where I get emotional and then,
you know,
my,
my initial instinct is to speak with
emotion and then regret what I say
afterwards when I calmed down.
And so I've really,
it showed an ugly side of me that
I'm not necessarily proud of.
And I've sat back and looked at more
perspective on the whole situation.
And not that I still don't condemn it,
but when you look at a guy's career,
I hate seeing guys like a Vandelay,
um,
like a Kung Lee go out with something
that happened towards the end of their
career that caused a black eye on it
and then have it ruin the entire body of
work that they perform.
Because right now the environment in
every professional sports pressures a lot
of guys to go towards that avenue.
I mean,
if,
if we're talking about what takes
place in mixed martial arts,
let's talk about the NFL.
If you lifted up that rock
and looked underneath it,
God bless you.
I mean needle you,
you have a couple of quarterbacks
and you'd have maybe a punter.
I even think those guys,
you know what I mean?
You had like a 47 year old guy,
I think kick a 53 yard or the other day.
Um,
you know,
I,
I mean,
so the environment is
there and I think if,
if,
if the sport in general goes towards
a comprehensive testing policy,
levels of playing field for everybody,
I think it makes a safer environment
longterm for the fighters.
And you know,
maybe,
maybe we'll get there in the next couple.
Yeah.
Well for fighters is a
gigantic issue of course,
because you're not talking about a
baseball where you can hit a ball better
basketball or anywhere,
you know,
you're running faster.
You're talking about a guy being able to
deliver more physical punishment to his
opponent and you know,
possibly score,
knock out that he wouldn't have been
able to score possibly lantus shot,
that he wouldn't have been able to
land had he not been essentially with
superhuman hormone levels.
And it's widely understood that,
especially in the early days of the UFC,
in the early days of pride,
there were a gigantic amount of guys who
are taking performance enhancing drugs.
I have a friend,
I will not name names.
Uh,
he fought for a Japanese organization
and they not only did they tell him to do
steroids,
they wanted him to fight
at a higher weight class.
They were going to help
him set everything up.
And you know,
they were even picking opponents
for him that he can beat.
And they were there.
You know,
they were setting the whole thing up.
But how like when you know about
that from the inside and you know,
like the organization telling
the guy to take steroids,
you know,
letting them know that it's okay,
we're not going to test you for that.
Uh,
that it had to be a major part of,
of MMA in the early.
Now those guys that came from those days,
now they have to adjust because
like you're looking at Vito,
like Vito who was on
testosterone replacement therapy,
you know,
had those incredible victories over Luke
Rockhold and Michael Bisping and you
know,
now those Dan Henderson
and now those fights,
not only they come into question like,
you've got to go,
man,
what does he have left?
Now that he's off that stuff and now he's
got to fight with natural testosterone
levels and he's going to fight
Chris Weidman for the title.
We know we're going to find out and
you're going to find out next month
the just passed his most recent,
I mean,
they've been tested them quite often.
The Egypt passes most recent
tests and absolutely right.
You know,
we're gonna find out and,
and you know,
the whole TRT ruling,
thank God it's gone because it
just clouded the issue I think.
And,
and gave at times a sport,
a black eye and,
and you know,
not only the sport,
but then it kind of screwed
over some fighters too.
If you're going to allow something
look than guys are going to do it,
you know,
they're going to find a way to do it.
Um,
but I think there's,
there's definitely been,
you know,
from what I've seen,
talking to camps,
talking to fires,
I'm calling all these cards now.
There has definitely been a difference.
The younger breed of fighters is very
anti performance handling drug a lot,
especially a lot of these wrestlers,
they're so used to being tested and this
is becoming like their NFL now coming
from amateur wrestling that,
that they're all for it.
And in a lot of that old breed
is really starting to go away.
And you know,
guys are starting to get
randomly tested out of the blue.
Yeah.
And that's important.
And randomly tested.
The UFC is doing these random tests where
they're doing the full Olympic blood
panel,
which is like $40,000
a fighter and you know,
they can only do so many of those.
And that's one of the
things that everybody knows.
So it's a bit of,
you know,
it's a bit of a game of musical chairs.
You know,
there's only a few chairs.
Everybody's moving around.
You're hoping that the music
doesn't stop and you're standing up.
Yep.
And I mean you're talking about over,
I think it's over 550 I think it
was five 85 we sit on UFC tonight,
fighters,
fighters on the roster.
And this is across the globe.
So if you want to start doing,
you know,
during their training camps,
random testing throughout the year
and all these different countries,
language barriers,
the labs,
all that.
I mean that is a monster.
And I'll tell you from private
meetings at Lorenzo Fertitta,
he is very determined to
find a way to make it work.
You know,
we've had some meetings and I think
it is in the hopper over time,
but right now it's just,
it's more piece mail where they can't
do it every single time here and there.
It's going to be,
hey,
on this card we're going to be able
to do three on this cargo to do for,
you know,
and they're going to contract out
and give the athletic commission the
Authority.
Here's the money.
You guys go partner with the
organization and take care of it.
Because you know,
as Dana said this week,
they don't want anything to do with that.
They've botched it in,
in areas already.
So they know they don't need to do it.
What's the [inaudible] yes,
yes.
Connolly is a fighter who was a,
um,
his entire career was,
you know,
he had like some really spectacular
victories over in strike force,
so great kicker.
And he had a real good
wrestling background to set
a very unusual style in that
he threw a lot of white wild taekwondo
style kicks but he was also really good
at stuffing takedowns and
could throw guys around.
Um,
came over to the UFC,
had some wins,
had some losses,
you know,
fought,
fought as hard out and then took his
last fight against Michael Bisping and
there was all these photographs of him
just looking different than he's ever
looked before.
Like we were talking about like this
radical change in his appearance.
He had this mad fucking six backwards.
You never saw that from him before.
And you know,
he said,
hey,
this is the first time I'm
healthy in a long time.
I'm doing a lot of strength
and conditioning but it's
just super odd to see
someone in their late thirties,
forties,
40 years old,
40 years,
40 years old being built
like that out of nowhere.
It's very,
very odd.
And I mean,
unless someone goes on like a
fucking vision quest for like,
you know,
seven,
nine months,
whatever,
and just radical fucking strength
and conditioning training,
you don't see that much of a
difference in a person's body.
Yeah.
Usually while you're working on
skills and you're sparring and you,
you know,
you're doing drills and you're doing
all the shit that you need to do to win
fights.
Yeah.
When you're,
when you're training like that,
it is so hard to then go hit the weight
room and get that kind of muscle density
and put on that kind of mass.
And I mean that's where
it gets really difficult.
And uh,
you know,
and it gets clean the story
with [inaudible] whichever.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yes.
I mean he goes into fight and I
remember it was a Saturday morning,
I was in Tulsa,
Oklahoma.
I was calling the fights that morning
and I wake up and my body's like,
Hey,
the fight pass card is on with putting on,
literally just woke up
cause it was in China.
And so fight takes place.
Michael Bisbing wins.
And at the same time,
I remember I was reading an article where
busying was talking about the picture
Kang took and you know,
busy Mike has always
been very vocal cities,
fought a bunch of TRT guys and he's
had some opportunity squandered in his
career.
And so then I pushed out the tweet where,
um,
it's a good start or didn't pay to cheat
for one's good start to the day and you
know,
it,
it's sent off,
you know,
a just a wildfire,
which all of a sudden I realized,
so yeah,
that was one of those emotional times
we're having the phone in my hand was to,
and you know what,
I'm older and I'm wiser than that.
And I,
it was,
it was one of those times and then,
you know,
it was told to me,
hey,
it's best to keep your
mouth shut right now.
Um,
you know,
afterwards.
So it was certainly not a
situation that I was proud of.
Regardless,
I'm always going to be for proper testing,
clean sport,
etc. But it is not my job to go
around making accusations or whatever,
that there's bodies to do that.
But it is certainly something that that
does get me emotional and it triggers a
side of me.
I'm not so proud of us aside
that speaks before thinking,
you know?
And that's been a real
good lesson learned for me.
You know,
over the course this year being a,
an official sports broadcast or not a
fighter who does commentating on the side,
you know,
and,
and that's something where there comes
a certain amount of responsibility with
this.
We not broadcasting audio.
Is that what's going on?
There's this
slight issue.
It seems to be recording.
Fine.
I'm recording it here.
What's the issue?
Not Hitting Ustream?
I don't know.
Why don't you reboot.
Okay.
Kill your Michael.
Um,
yeah,
I mean that's,
that is a transition,
right?
I mean it's like,
it's also like you're
speaking from the heart,
but if you were in the gym,
if you walked in the gym and you were
talking to a bunch of guys in the gym,
that'd be a normal conversation.
Absolutely.
But you did it publicly.
And when you do it publicly,
you invite every fucking troll and all
these certainly dorks that just sit in
front of the computer waiting for
something like this to talk about.
Do you get angry at you?
And I don't,
you know,
I don't follow my own personal,
look,
if that is a conversation I should have
with him first before I ever go anywhere
else.
And you know,
I actually tried to contact
him a few days after and,
and you know,
he had just lost the fight.
He wasn't,
he wasn't ready to speak.
And so,
um,
you know,
it,
it's,
it's one of those situations
where where you live and learn,
you know,
and you'll learn the hard
way when you do something,
but at the same time,
uh,
you know,
it,
it's not one of those situations where
it's going to make me back down from,
from stating right from
wrong in this sport,
in standing up for what's right.
And you were saying that he was ready
to take the nine months suspension.
He was ready to take the
nine months suspension.
Then they changed it to 12 and then
they started having this a quarter.
Yeah.
According to,
to the UFC.
So there was something where,
you know,
his camp was ready to take the
nine month and then instead,
you know,
when it got up to 12,
that's where they fought it and ended
up beating it and then everything had to
be rescinded.
Well,
he,
they ended up beating it because the
way that the tests were handled was
incorrect.
The way that the tests were
administered was incorrect.
It was all done by someone that
the UFC had hired to do it,
but it wasn't done to the protocol.
Yeah.
The lab,
the lab couldn't know.
The lab was not capable of,
of actually testing accurately
for human growth hormone,
which is what they said he failed for.
So that's kind of a disaster
and it was an absolute disaster,
absolute disaster,
which is really why the
UFC has now abandoned,
you know,
trying to do this and,
and you know,
they've taken a step
backwards to evaluate.
It's really fascinating to
me because the sport is,
um,
it's the most intense and the most,
in my opinion,
the most dangerous sport in a sense
that you have so much on the line.
Like if you lose a,
an auto race,
auto races are dangerous
and you could crash,
you could die.
And there's no doubt about that.
It's a very dangerous game.
Football also very game.
But there's something about losing a
fight that is so much more personal.
There's so much more on the line.
It's so much different
than any other loss.
You lose a basketball game at fuck,
we lost,
you know,
let's have a beer.
Let's say you lose a fight,
man.
It's a fucking life changing event.
Tremendous,
tremendous.
There's,
well one,
there's no teammates to point to,
you know,
it's just you and the
other guy in the ring.
You sometimes you get guys who will use
the referees and excuse that judges an
excuse and you're on a 50% pay scale.
So when,
when,
when I would fight,
you know,
I would get $40,000 to show up
and fight and 40,000 more to win.
That's a tremendous difference.
That's a lot of months of
pay in the mortgage debt.
That's,
you know,
a big chunk that I can then put away for
the future and what I need to do as a
fighter for when I retire.
There's a lot of that.
So it becomes very personal.
Not to mention you're standing
your contract negotiations,
who you fight next,
how soon you fight next.
All these things go into a
play and depending on how
you lose for fighter loses
by a vicious knockout,
how much of that just
shortness his career?
So there's a lot on the line and in a
big part of that is the reason why people
are so intrigued by this sport.
That's why they want to
watch it because they know,
wow,
these guys,
they lay it on the line.
This,
this is different than any other sport.
Who are these people that are capable
of making that walk in doing that?
And that,
that really I think is,
is part of the reason why people are so,
uh,
it,
it eager to watch the sport and get
so interested in so involved in it.
That victory incentive that
doesn't exist in boxing does it?
You don't have,
they don't have a win loss thing and
Boston as far as like 50 to win 50,
you know,
50 to show 50 to win,
then that's not,
does that exist in boxing?
It May.
I've never seen,
it's usually a contracted amount.
It's a contract amount.
That's an issue,
isn't it?
I mean it's,
I think the UFC likes it
because it makes people,
it gives them an incentive to fight,
but God damn,
don't they already have
the incentive to fight.
You know,
it,
it's,
it's one of those things where when you
talk to Joe Silva about some of those
things,
he,
he has some,
some very strong ideologies on
it since he's been there so long,
you know,
at,
there's one point where they did finish
bonuses for anybody who finished on the
car.
He said that was a complete failure.
Um,
you know,
so it's interesting.
That would be a pretty cool,
you know,
to pull all the data,
put it into some kind of model and see,
you know.
But in my opinion,
it seems like to me it's,
it's financially more beneficial to win
long term than it is to take a whole lot
of risks.
Of course.
Yeah.
Without a doubt.
And it's also,
I mean you only have so many fights in
your career and if you're extending your
yourself and you're,
you're putting yourself in danger to try
to eek out a win and fighting in maybe
what you would call it,
a non technical way or
fighting in a reckless way,
you'll longtime,
you're gonna cost yourself money.
Absolutely.
Because you're,
you're going to take shots he wouldn't
take and you're going to put yourself
there.
It's a short term gamble that really is
only beneficial to the folks that are
watching it in the UFC.
Yeah.
And when you look at it,
you know,
from,
from spending the last year calling
fights and I've really gotten to know Joe
Silva,
Sean Shelby a lot better than
I did when I was a fighter.
I've seen them reward the guys,
you know,
there there was a missed miscommunication
or I think some guys just had it
wrong.
You know,
back when I fought were,
hey,
I got to go in there and brawl.
I've seen them reward guys very well
for going out there and fighting.
Very similar how Frankie
Edgar Foc Cub Swanson,
he didn't go out there
and trade with them.
He went out there,
he moved around duty to do,
shot the take down and dominated
the fight on the ground.
Then gets the finish the very last
few seconds of the fifth round and,
and they absolutely love
the fight like that.
So I don't,
I think that fighters need to realize,
look,
go in there and get the fight
finished as fast as you can.
And when in most dominant fashion,
what I've seen where they get
frustrated with his word guys,
we'll ride certain positions out.
They get inside the guard,
make no attempt to pass to do more damage.
They get inside the clench.
They're happy to just hold them against
the cage for a while until the referee
separates them.
I think that's some of the things that
get them a little frustrated when,
when guys will win fights like that,
but then ask for major things after it's,
hey,
I want a better contract and went higher
profile matchups I want to be in the
main Carter.
I want to be the main event
and for,
for folks that are not
familiar with training camps,
there's one thing that has to be taken
into consideration when you watch a
fight.
When you see a guy may
be stalling like that,
that guy might've fought injured,
he might've fought sick,
he might have gotten injured during camp
and not being able to train correctly,
so he has to take advantage of what,
what little opportunities sometimes that
he can get to take a break because he
doesn't have the gas tank to go all out.
Absolutely.
You can't tell by looking at a guy.
No,
you're on the wall.
When you're warmed up like that,
you're going to be able to
move through certain injuries,
but it doesn't mean you have as much pop
on your punch or your kick with that,
you know,
with that portion of your body.
You know,
it was funny because,
um,
I get it all the time,
man,
that fight with you and
Vandelay Silva was awesome,
but why did you,
why did you fight him
like that and you know,
I'll tell him,
you know,
honestly,
I flew to Japan and,
and I actually,
I tore a part of my hip
the second day there.
It was real stiff from the training
camp and I would overtrain bad,
you know,
it was,
it was a big problem for me.
I always thought the more I could do,
the better I'd be so I couldn't
lift my left knee to my chest.
And,
and it's funny cause Doctor d
who flies into all the events,
he had to come right to my hotel
room as soon as he got there.
And I said,
hey,
just give me a light cane,
completely allowable by the commission.
It's legal,
it will numb it,
be good to go,
couldn't get it,
and Tokyo and so,
all right,
well you don't have to
find a way around it.
And this happens.
All fighters who knows.
I mean Vandelay could have
easily showed up to that,
you know,
with,
with something torn in his body as well.
And so,
you know,
you go in there round one and Iraq
them if they are right and well,
this guy's got a lot of miles on them.
One more shot and I'll finish this thing.
Oh Shit.
He just knocked me down,
you know?
And then it just,
it kind of started going
back and forth and uh,
you know,
it's one of those fights,
you almost blackout and you just
get lost in the violence and,
and knowing you're
putting on a great fight.
Um,
that even,
you know,
when I woke up and I started
to realize what happened,
which was when Jon Anik
starts interviewed me,
I was like,
God,
I lost,
you know,
it's one of those things where,
all right,
you know,
but at least I went out on my shield.
The fights that really haunt you are the
ones where you go home and you're like,
man,
I could've pushed a little harder.
I could have done this.
I could've done that.
That was a wild fucking fire.
You and Val van de la,
you know,
whatever you say,
whatever you want about
performance enhancing drugs.
And he did run a Wa Vandelay
suspended for life for who?
Don't know the
whole story.
He ran away from a random drug test.
They showed up at his gym and
literally ran out the door.
He was like,
I got to go see it.
And they suspended him for life,
which is really unprecedented.
And in my opinion it's kind of fucked
up because the guy is a legend.
And one of my all time favorite fighters,
if not my all time kills me to,
to see,
you know,
look,
he absolutely,
people should be punished
for what they did wrong.
But let's,
and I've actually said
this in a couple of years,
I don't know if they ever saw,
but eight let's,
let's not completely black
out the entire career.
You know,
there,
there are hall of fame Worthy Martial
Artists who they screwed up like every
other human being in there.
Hey,
call a spade a spade and make
them stand accountable for it.
But at the end of the day they have
an entire body of work to look upon.
But isn't it true though,
I mean some of these guys that
are hall of fame type guys,
Hall of fame caliber guys most likely
were cheating their entire careers.
I mean,
that's,
there's a big percentage of guys
who you could point a finger at,
especially guys that
are fighting in Japan.
And if you talk to the
guys who fought in Japan,
they will tell you that,
yeah,
this is what was going on.
Mark Coleman told me,
he went backstage and he saw
Vandelay oiling up his body.
He saw him oil.
He's like,
the fuck you doing man,
you can't do that.
They were oiling up so that
nobody can take it down.
Circus.
Back then,
that organization was an absolute circus.
And for people that are listening,
it is light years different in the UFC.
Oh yeah.
Um,
but yeah,
that,
that was an absolute circus.
They let fighters fight like fights.
It should have never taken place.
Like how about Bob Sapp 375 pounds.
Fought to Maura interests
like one 85 right.
Any anything?
I mean,
literally if they could have put a
tiger in there with a human being,
they knew they would have made
money off that and they wouldn't,
they would have absolutely done that.
If they could find a way to
not go to jail afterwards,
they would have done it.
You know,
they put together some
fucking ridiculous shows.
What about Hong Man Choi versus fader?
Remember that?
I mean,
hung Troy was like seven feet tall.
He weighed 300 who knows
what the fuck pounds.
He was a legitimate giant.
He absolutely w with,
with less athleticism and his body
than my five year old daughter.
Yeah.
Well the poor guy was like,
oh,
he's bones probably weighed
as much as this fucking table.
I mean,
he was just,
he was a mess.
I mean,
physically he had fucking
tumor in his pituitary gland.
I mean,
he,
that's why the same as
big foot Silva Silva,
who's still fights for the UFC,
still an elite fighter.
I mean that poor fucking guy.
I mean,
he's a guy who legitimately
needs testosterone replacement
therapy and he can't
have it and he's got to have a,
some operation on his head now and
now he's gonna Fight Frank Mir.
Right.
Cause he's got Frank Mir coming up.
Look,
God bless him.
I mean,
the guy's still in there throwing,
but he's,
he's a guy who legitimately needs it.
Fucking Nogueira.
We've,
we played it a couple of weeks ago.
We did a fight companion and watched
Nogueira versus Bob Sab own fucking
Nogueira got pile drive quite 375 pound.
Bob Sat picked him up and dropped him
and Noguera's weight on Noguera's head.
It was the fucking most horrendous thing
to ever watch someone do to someone.
You're like,
Oh God.
And me and mom knew Gurwin
went on to win that fight,
which shows you how tough
deck guy was back then.
Then that dude is,
I saw him in Rio just a few weeks
ago and it was so cool to seek his,
you know,
everyone was just sitting at this,
this little bar,
and it was right next to
the restaurant in the hotel.
And when he came walking downstairs
is humble as can humanly be.
He comes down,
everybody stood up,
not just presents,
but everybody associated with fighting
stood up out of respect for this guy who,
you know,
the day he retire should be immediately
put into the UFC hall of fame.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean,
there should be some sort of
a martial arts hall of fame,
you know,
like not just the UFC,
just to all schools,
all disciplines.
You know,
he's in there for sure.
I mean,
he explained,
he showed how you could win fights off
your back and the heavyweight division,
which nobody was doing.
Worries.
Triangling Mark Coleman,
who the fuck is going
to try and Mark Coleman,
he's going to pick it up and slam me.
I mean,
and mark home and by the way,
fighting in pride,
most likely on a variety
of Mexican supplements.
I mean,
he's fucking,
he looks insane.
He was enormous.
He was so good back then too.
I mean,
that was mark,
you know,
like during the days where he won the
pride heavyweight Grand Prix leather skin,
fucking animal.
Mark Coleman.
I was there.
I'm of the first fight
ever worked was UFC 12.
And that was when Mark Coleman won the
UFC heavyweight title beat Dan Severn.
He got him in a fucking judo headlock
and just almost pulled his head off.
It was the old school yard,
the school yard moving.
Well it wasn't,
it wasn't quite the school yard move.
He was like,
he was kind of in like side control,
but laying on top of them and he had
his head and he was just fucking Yank.
And can I forget the,
you know,
catch wrestling Josh Barnett?
Isn't that what he got?
Dean lister in us?
And then,
uh,
all Sinek who's a current UFC heavyweight
who's two and o right now at 47 years
old in the UFC,
he's a heavyweight.
He tapped out cre tech,
the three guys in a row at that technique.
It's brutal.
Oh yeah.
If a guy gets you like that,
especially a guy like Josh Barnett,
he's got a ridiculous grip.
He gets you in that position
and good night fucks.
I mean fucking tab dean
lister who's a Abu Dhabi,
great.
One of the best submission wrestlers
in the world means something.
If you can't,
that guy a bad dude.
He's a bad motherfucker and he is the
best representative in my opinion,
in all of modern MMA for catch wrestling.
I mean he really is a
student of that game.
He really understands that sport.
That was the fight when
he fought Daniel Cormay.
That was a fight that woke me up.
You know,
when you see us at me mean caught me.
I wouldn't have like eight,
nine fights at that point in time.
I'm not sure.
I mean,
he had barely any,
any experience.
And he goes in there and beats a guy
like Josh Barnett were granted his
wrestling game.
A major advantage in that.
But you know,
still Barnett's,
a crafty guy.
You make any mistakes in there.
He's going to catch you.
Screen keeps
going.
Black over here.
Jamie,
is this not real?
I don't know.
It's still going out.
Okay.
It's not on.
Not on my fucking computer.
It's not,
yeah.
All their goes,
came back.
Uh,
yeah.
Josh Barnett is a very good wrestler too.
So to see Daniel Cormier launch
him through the air like that.
And the same thing he
did to Dan Henderson,
who fuck has ever done that.
Dan Henderson,
I trained the first time
that traded Daniel Cormier,
we were all doing one
of these shows here in,
in La.
And he's like,
Hey,
let's,
let's get a session in today.
And so we go to this tiny little gym
and it's got one of those really small
cages.
I mean,
you know,
I could lay across at night almost be,
as long as the Cajun,
I'm trained to a core mia
and he's picking me up.
I mean,
if he wanted to throw me
right out of this octagon,
I've never had a man
picked me up that easy.
Once his hips pop,
you're in the air and it just,
it shows the kind of leverage and be,
you know,
the length and the technique that Jon
Jones has to have stopped that repeatedly
and stifle those attempts.
Yeah.
When the one time that Daniel
did take them down like that,
it was for a second and John was back
up to his feet like he was on springs
wouldn't even have been scored
a takedown in wrestling news.
Yeah.
I mean he'd belly down
immediately and pop Rebecca.
It was incredible.
Yeah.
John is a freak.
I mean,
he's a real freak athlete,
you know.
And the crazy part is he,
you know,
I don't know if John's ever been in
a Jujitsu class in shrimped before.
Really like [inaudible] he's never
lifted weights in between fights.
To my knowledge.
He doesn't train.
The key comes,
he does his seven to nine week camp.
He leaves martial arts is over at the,
he's got a heavy bag in his basement,
his house in New York that
he'll hit her once in a while.
Like I'm dead serious.
And so now he's actually
moving to Albuquerque and
saying how I'm going to train
year round.
I mean it's,
you know,
aside from all the other
things going on with him,
he,
he's obviously got some
things to take care of,
but he comes out of this,
the other end in search
training year round.
It's really,
really scary.
I mean,
the guy,
he never lifts weights in between fights.
He just comes in and start
lifting then that's so incredible.
It's so crazy.
It doesn't train in between fights.
So what does he do in between fights?
Just hangs out.
He's got nothing there.
He lives in Ithaca,
Ithaca,
New York.
I drove when I was supposed to,
when I was fighting Phil Davis,
they gave me that fight.
It was right after I had
just fought in December.
I had just had a baby.
And so we were,
we already had plane tickets
booked to go to Pennsylvania.
You see some family for
Christmas where I'm from.
And so man,
I got to train with some wrestlers.
I'm them fighting this
guy named Phil Davis,
who I can't find any footage on,
but I know he's a national champion.
I'm not really a good
matchup for this guy.
So of course,
you know,
I end up driving all the way up to upstate
New York to try and train with John.
And I'm trained in some,
I don't know if it was like
Ithaca College summat somewhere.
He shows up in sweat pants and
tosses me all over the place.
I mean,
he didn't know anything back then.
He knew a little bit of wrestling.
He didn't know any Jujitsu,
he didn't know how to strike.
He was watching the first
day and Greg Jackson's gym,
he's a call man.
I watched all these youtube
videos and Muhammad Ali.
So he goes in there and he's got his
hands down and he snapped and jabs playing
the rope,
a dope with Muhammad Ali and just,
you know,
toasting everybody what a freak.
Greg was running around the gym,
running around the gym saying
till his wife saying to me that,
that's my next champion.
That's my next champion.
At the time,
I was still at light heavyweight.
So Greg politely said,
well,
after you Brian,
and I looked at him,
I said,
look,
Greg,
I'm,
I'm old enough and mature enough that
that I can tell you right off the bat,
look you,
you could,
you could save that shit for someone else.
All right,
well that's rare and that's one of
the reasons why you've been able to
transition successfully into a career
in broadcasting is that like you,
you let it go like in a
way that very few guys do.
Like you,
you let it go with many,
many miles still left on your engine.
You just decided,
you know what?
I'm okay.
I'm good.
I'm young,
I'm healthy.
I can still fight for sure.
You could still compete
at the highest level,
but you decided and yeah,
I'm good.
You know,
and there was a couple,
you know,
there are a couple things to it.
Um,
one,
you know,
when,
when I got knocked out by Vandelay I knew
right then that night in my hotel room
that I was done.
If I can't beat a fighter
who's an aging fighter who yes,
he's one of the best of all
time ds and aging fighter.
I'm now taking a step backwards.
I had to evaluate because I
played football for 14 years.
Um,
got hit with a few LEDs and Iraq.
I mean there's a few
indicators here and then,
you know,
I,
I trained in the air and came up in MMA
where it was you go to war twice a week
in sparring.
Yeah.
That was a different era.
Right now they're just starting to,
you're starting to see
those guys in the gym.
The 10 year later,
guys that are still,
you know,
sort of in the sport but have diminished
considerably in their faculties have
diminished considerably.
And that's the,
that's a big issue that a lot of people
have is those guys that nobody talks to,
those guys that are still around and you
get a chance to see what that style of
training can do to you.
Now you've seen a lot of
guys who were training there.
If you've kind good training partners,
you can get so much better by
not hitting each other harm.
So Lou,
and that's something that people
have a hard time accepting.
Everybody wants everybody to be tough.
Most fucking guys in
the UFC already tough.
They don't have to take
punches to be tough,
you know,
it's just what you need to
do is work on your reflexes,
your timing,
your technique,
and then the skillset
working on strategies,
working on understanding what to do in
various positions were to never be what
to do if you find yourself in a place
that instead of just winging it on
toughness,
which you'll see,
you're still seeing,
you're still seeing guys fight at the
highest level with their fucking Chin up
in the air,
their hands down and they're winging
punches and they're going in.
And you know,
occasionally it works and
occasionally it doesn't.
And they're,
and they're,
they're flipping coins
when they do it and it's,
you know,
it's exactly right.
And a big part of my focus when I
get to visit with all these fighters,
before I call their fights,
I'll talk to him about that.
You know,
your objective is to make the maximum
amount of money for as long as you can in
your career.
Fight as many times a year as you can.
And I'll always ask them,
do you get paid in the gym?
Of course they look at me like I'm stupid.
No,
I don't.
You could pay when you fight.
Right?
So why,
why are you fighting in the gym?
You can look,
I'm guilty
of,
and I use it myself.
I,
for years never got rocked.
And I spar with some
really hard hitting guys.
You know,
Jardeen Rashad Evans,
you know,
some really good guys that that would
get after I would never get rocked.
All of a sudden,
you know,
towards the end of my career,
my last two camps,
I started to notice,
man,
I'm starting to get some headaches.
You know,
I started,
you know,
feeling the repercussions of training
so hard for so many years and instead of
focusing on sparring partners
that can mimic my opponent,
I'm just focusing on winning in
the gym against various level guys.
We're going to go 100% against me.
And,
and that takes away from your career,
cuts it short,
and it cuts down that window to where you
can make that maximum amount of money.
You know,
we're,
you look at these guys now
that are getting smarter,
just like you said,
and they're tracking that sort of thing.
You know,
Mark Henry counts how many strikes
Frankie Edgar puts out a sparring session
because when they do their game plan,
you need to fight at this pace.
I want this many strikes per round.
This what you have to do to win the fight.
So he'll watch Frankie sparring the whole
camp to make sure he's on pace to win
that fight for what they
feel he'll need to do to win.
And he's using like a clicker.
Yes.
Mark Henry's one of the most
underrated trainers in the game today.
He's a guy who does not
get enough credit and I,
I've talked to shop cause Shab did some
training down there with a Frankie Edgar
and he was like,
this guy's got fucking notebook after
notebook filled with all the different
strategies,
techniques,
things they're working on,
things to do for very fighters.
I mean you look what he did the cub,
I mean cubs a fucking monster.
He is such a good fighter.
And Frankie shut him down it and cubs
a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu and,
and he got into half guard and
really he knew what to do from there.
But because of the continuous strikes,
I mean it was a pace on tiny,
not even just in the
striking room but on top.
Yeah.
Frankie never stopped punching,
which when you're punching
a guy and half guard,
it makes you a threat to pass them
out past to full side control.
It made cub worry more
about retaining half guard,
maybe get back to full guard
than blocking the punches,
hitting his face.
And on top of that,
every time a guy's punching you,
you can't breathe.
So every time a guys punching you,
you're tightening up your,
you're constricting your body when
he's punching your body and you're,
you're cutting in cutting back
on the amount of oxygen to get.
That's like one of the strategies and
Nick Diaz is always used in his career.
He'll hit a guy 150 times at like 50%
he just gets in front of your face and
starts throwing punches
and people are like,
oh,
those aren't even hurt.
Yes.
That first of all,
yes they do.
Yes they do.
You don't know what the
fuck you're talking about.
Let Him Punch him 50% it
might not knock you dead,
but it fucking hurts and he
hits you with four of those.
It's probably almost as good as one full
full blast punch is going to hit you
with a bunch of them and you're
not going to be able to breathe.
You're going to be tightening
up constantly toe a Paul Daley,
Robbie Lawler knocked both out.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Those are just two of the examples
of what he's able to do and you know,
he has good accuracy mean
he'll knock them out.
He's pretty pinpoint when he goes and
hits a guy in the chin rate when they
think it's not hurting,
then he does drop them and it's a
suffocating style because I feel,
and I don't know if there's
science that backs up,
I haven't researched a bit.
When you're exhausted,
you're easier to get knocked out.
You know,
you can't tense up as much when you
and roll with the punches as much.
You end up taking it square and it rocks.
The jaw crushes the
nerves and in your own,
yeah,
there's no doubt.
And you know those fights,
man.
God Damn.
Especially the Paul daily fight.
His Chin is another thing.
I mean,
you can't teach that.
You can't teach the ability to
absorb punishment that he has.
I mean,
it's just,
he's so tough and the psychology to,
you know,
to walk into an octagon
for all these people,
everybody you know and care about in the
world is going to watch that fight and
you've got to face him afterwards and,
and your decision,
I mean,
you talk about the fight or flight
and they're still fighters who,
even though they're professional
fighters and they're there,
are way tougher than your normal populace.
You know,
there's,
there's level,
many subtle levels.
Once you get to the highest level,
Nick Diaz doesn't,
he doesn't care.
He's going to go toe to toe with you.
It doesn't matter who it is.
You know,
Anderson Silva,
he's going to go toe to toe with
them and there's no issues there.
Even though he hasn't been
in the octagon a long time.
There's,
there's something psychologically
in that man where,
hey,
you know what?
If you tell me you're going to draw a
line and fight that I'm there and he'll
admit he didn't even like fighting.
Yeah.
Which is pretty crazy.
It's tough.
He wants that money.
You know what I mean?
He made a lot of money in the George
Saint Pierre fight and then took a long
time off and now he's coming back and
fighting Anderson Silva on the Andersons
comeback fight,
which is man,
what a lot of questions and that fight,
right?
That's fights all.
It's one big room.
That should be the poster
for that fucking fight.
Just a question mark.
Who the fuck knows what's
going to happen in that fight?
And most people will look at say,
well you know Dee has going to come
out and he's going to want to box and
Anderson just has so
many weapons on the feet.
But how does he throw those weapons?
And you know,
we haven't seen the Diaz
brothers do too many leg check,
checking leg kicks yet.
You know,
certainly Nate didn't do it
against how Hilda Santos.
But if Nick Diaz or if you have Nick
Diaz comes out there and he checks a few
leg kicks for Anderson,
does that slow down the attack?
You know,
does he hit the same area again?
Does he check that?
Who knows?
I mean,
you know,
if I have to bet money,
I'm going to put it on the all time.
Great Anderson Silva,
but I'm not quite ready to count out
Nick Diaz out of this fight just yet.
I'm not counting them out at all.
And Anderson Silva for folks who
don't know what we're talking about,
is the greatest of all time,
broke his leg in his last
fight through a kick,
Chris Weidman lift up his knee.
Anderson caught him in
the top part of the Shin,
which is a brutal spot to get checked.
And Anderson's leg snapped like a twig.
It was really,
I've only seen it happened twice
live Corey hill long time ago.
Who looked like a guy who would break.
I mean,
Cory was really tall for the weight class.
Was he fighting one 55 one
55 that was a disgusting cut.
Oh,
he was really,
really,
really thin.
And uh,
I mean probably take something
out of your bones too.
I mean,
it takes something out
of your organs for sure.
Super Bad for your kidneys and these guys
are dehydrating themselves like that.
But Corey breaking his
leg was very shocking.
But there was something about watching
Anderson break his leg where you just
know the Anderson isn't
all time great.
The all time great.
The,
the most spectacular performer
we've ever seen in the UFC,
in his neck,
his leg just snapped the,
the best martial artists
in my opinion,
in the history of martial arts.
Do you mean when you look at like the end,
you want to talk about,
you know,
Benny,
the jet bill superfoot Wallace and
you have Bruce Lee and yet all that,
you know,
and you can go way back in
history path pavers for sure.
Absolutely.
You've got to then look at Anderson
Silva and how he was able to bring to the
most complete fighting style known demand.
The artistry he brought to it,
the many different ways he
want from different kicks,
a submission to me,
he can,
he can do it all.
I still think the greatest fighter to
ever go in the octagon is John Jones.
So I don't think any,
I don't think anybody has ever beat that.
The level competition he's beaten by,
uh,
by the margins that he's done.
So,
I mean,
drops me Cheetah unconscious to the floor.
the way he's done it,
he submitted [inaudible] after he got
his arm fucked up and that arm bar and
refuse to tap.
Yup.
You know what I mean?
Fought Gustafson and from all indications,
barely fucking trained for that fight
and still gutted it out in those final
rounds.
And one,
it's funny you bring that.
I mean that,
that's,
that's what I've heard as well.
I don't know if they're true,
but that's certainly the rumblings.
You know,
that,
that that was,
there was some stuff taken lately.
It's very rare when you hear those
rumblings and they're not true.
I mean,
when was it half the time you
heard of that guy barely trained.
You're like,
what the fuck you talking about?
The guy was doing two a days.
He was running five miles.
He was eating nothing but the,
the most wholesome foods.
That's not what I heard.
I heard he was doing the exact opposite.
He was eating some very unwholesome foods.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean when,
when he fought shogun for the title or
the worst beatings I've seen inside the
octagon,
he in fucking top line knee and his
opening move is he's the youngest guy to
ever fight for the UFC title.
He throws a fuck,
not the youngest guy to
ever fight for a title.
I believe that was John Alessio.
I think John Alessia was 20 when he fought
patent military way back in the day.
But you know,
he's got to win it.
Youngest just got to win.
It throws a fucking flying
knee on Shogun and cracks.
I'm right in the chin.
I mean,
I mean just ridiculous stuff that he
throw me through what he try flying armbar
and core me.
I got a theory about that shit man.
My theory is that guys who grow up with
brothers that beat the fuck out of them
or just on a completely different level,
cause Weidman grew up with a
brother to beat the fuck out of him.
Matt Hughes and his brother
beat the fuck out of each other.
John Jones had two super athlete brothers.
He's got two brothers that are fucking
NFL studs and you know his brother Arthur
by all all indications kicks John's
ass when they work out together.
Yeah.
And He'd,
he'd kicked John's ass,
grown up plenty.
And he was a state champion
wrestler I believe yet.
Huge guy too.
Huge.
Yeah,
he's 300 plus.
And when you grow up like that,
I think you just have a level of tea.
I think also your body develop stronger.
You know,
Muse is something about
tangling with a brother,
your whole,
I mean you're in competition
from the time you're a baby,
you're always going to war.
And coupled with that,
I have not seen in a guy
like John the belief,
you know John Will,
you know,
he'll watch a movie about like cheat
or something and I'm making this up
obviously and and health
think it truly exists in him.
So he has,
he meditates near a waterfall
the day of his fight always.
They got to find water,
he's got to go to water and you know,
he sits there and he'll
meditate and he focuses on,
most guys would point to that and say,
that is the dumbest thing I've ever seen.
They try and make fun of
somebody for John doesn't care.
John,
you know,
being in the locker room with him for
several fights from the same card.
He's back there as this young kid
who has very few life experiences.
So calm.
Never once as a thought of him
losing run through his mind.
I mean when he went out
and fought Vladimir,
met your Shanko.
I fought in that cart and,
and John's Jujitsu.
I had submitted him several
times in that training camp.
He goes out there against flatty and the
game plan was to strike with him cause
Laddie was such a good restaurant.
So get on the ground and John
wasn't good on the ground.
Immediately takes Vladimir
down past his guard,
elbows him into oblivion.
The,
the fights over.
I didn't know that John even knew
how to pass the guard at that point.
I'm serious.
You know,
you don't do beginners Jujitsu
classes at Greg Jackson's gym.
He'll do it in like
private sessions with them,
you know,
but,
but John,
it just,
you know,
I remember submitting them
several times when we can.
Then two weeks later we're in Denver,
Colorado for that camp
and he catches me in,
in a submission.
I look at Greg,
I go,
did he learn Jujitsu in two weeks?
You know,
it's just always been that way.
The only other guy that I hear that's
like that to that extreme for every move
they learn they could use
it instantly is Weidman.
Really.
When I talked to guys and I go
into hens those frequently for the,
the nonprofit I run,
there's a lot of guys up in Wall Street
who have been very generous and are very
avid for veterans getting jobs and
they'll always meet me at handles and they
train there and the guys there,
we'll talk about it like,
you know,
uh,
he,
he sit there in these classes and it
takes me thousands of reps to get this
moved to work on high level competition.
Weidman learns it,
drills it once,
and then submits everybody
in the class with that.
He's just that much of
an animal and you know,
he's a fucking,
when you get a stud wrestler
that picks up Jujitsu,
what a fucking horrific
combination that is.
Especially for guys like me
and I mean it absolutely right.
Anybody,
man.
Yeah.
You know,
I,
you know Eric Bradley is wrestler.
I don't,
he don't,
he was training at
Eddie's for awhile and uh,
I uh,
we were doing this drill where,
I mean he's not much bigger than me.
He'd make maybe 15 pounds,
but we're doing this drill.
We're doing this neat
Abelli belly drill and a,
you know,
you started out with neon belly
and see how long you can hold it.
He might as well had,
it might have,
might as well have had
a building on top of me.
Might as well have had a
fucking full foundation,
a few cars parked in,
in the building.
I mean,
I wasn't getting up.
I got on top of him,
he threw me off.
Like I was like,
who's getting out of bed?
And it's throwing off the covers.
It was just ridiculous.
It's it since there's a a kid
just like that.
His name is Raymond Jordan and he
wrestled with Tyron Woodley and Ben asking
verse and Missouri and he was younger
than those guys and he was a two time all
American.
There never was a
national champion though.
And Woodley will tell you is like,
I won't touch rain anymore,
won't touch it.
And so he went to go be Jordan Burroughs
main partner while he went and won
gold.
And I actually had him come to Atlanta
to help me train for four weeks before I
fought Michael Bisman.
The first week he was there,
the UFC cameras were in town.
And you know,
you had me,
you had Tom Watson who fights in the UFC.
You had Douglas Lema,
who's the Bella tour
champion was in there,
uh,
Juan Carnero,
who's coming back to the
UFC and fight Mark Munoz.
And then here's Raymond Jordan that this
kid who's never done this shit really
before.
He was beating everybody so
bad that the UFC camera said,
Brian,
this is some of the best
footage we've ever gotten,
but we can't use any of it.
Who is this kid?
And he doesn't want to fight.
It does.
He was was the Russell amounts he mounts
INTAPP's high level worldclass level
black belts cause he's,
he's got that same funky
style on the mat that these,
these Missouri Tigers have.
He's most natural athlete I've ever met.
Everything he throws is hard by the way.
Um,
just doesn't want,
he's just not interested in,
that's so crazy.
So what does he do?
Just coaches restaurant.
I helped him get a job.
He works at a company called
Med assets and it's the,
it's run by the gentleman who chairs
the board of the company I run.
And he's also brilliant by the way.
He's an African American kid who
grew up with a crack dealing uncle.
Both his parents are dead by six.
And you would think this
kid graduated from Harvard.
He,
he's an anomaly and he's brilliant.
And so he works in finance with them
and does deal analysis for a fortune 500
company poker traded companies.
Awesome.
So just doesn't have the desire to fight.
No.
You know,
he looks say sa,
you know,
he's been grinding for so long with
wrestling and I think it burnt them out.
You know,
a lot of those guys,
it's tough.
Is there a sport where people
overtrained more than in wrestling?
No.
I mean it teaches a mental
toughness and that is true.
There's no doubt about it that wrestlers
can perform and come back and in and
push in ways that a lot of guys
and other sports as they did,
they never developed that gear,
that sort of extra gear that you see
like a guy like Johnny Hendricks have or
you see like some of these wrestlers have.
But then you get a guy like Robbie Lawler
who has a fucking gear and you know,
he had a little bit of
a wrestling background,
but it was never like an NCAA national
champion or anything along those lines.
Yeah.
The odds are definitely
higher coming out of that,
you know,
uh,
that population,
you,
when you,
when you look at that,
that talent pool of amateur
wrestlers in really in any country,
I mean,
look at the kids were
getting in from Dagestan now.
I mean these guys are animals and it's
not just because of their combat sambo
and wrestling background.
I mean you'd go,
I would love to go over there and see
how could be Abner Maga Madoff grew up,
the hardships saying it's just
a different kind of people,
you know,
they're not nearly as spoiled is.
Most of our asses are over here.
State side.
That's a,
that's without a doubt a fact.
How beep number good Madoff
is the scariest guy at one 55
next to Paris in my opinion.
I can't wait for him to get healthy.
I mean I'm looking forward to those
angels fighting Pedis Cause I think
stylistically it's a
very intriguing fight.
But then you watch what Norma men off did.
A Dos Anjos he just fucking shut up.
I watched that fight again the other day.
He just racked all of them.
Everybody.
He does it to everybody and he's not a,
you look at him,
he doesn't look like Tyron Woodley.
You know,
he doesn't look like you
look at Tyron Woodley.
If he smashed his,
somebody go,
well Jesus,
look at the guy.
Yeah,
I mean look at the guy,
but you look at number commander,
if he looks like an athlete for
sure it looks like a strong guy,
but the way he's fucking rag doll on
people is shocking the way he did it to
able to Hilo.
I mean just like people
shocking hables a a stud.
Athletes are strong as hell,
you know,
it's,
near Morgan that have his kinesthetic
awareness in his leverage in technique.
And then I think they're,
the real key ingredient though is his
will guys that have that wrestling back
and they have that gear.
If you don't believe someone can stop you,
it's so powerful.
And he has that and the
talent and that's really,
really scary.
Yeah.
He fights like a werewolf.
I mean there's something about him.
It's like he's like his intensity
and violence is just so heightened.
It's like a as next level,
just whatever it is.
I mean if his striking ever
catches up to his grappling,
Jesus fucking Christ man.
I mean,
and it most likely will,
I mean depending on what's
the state of his knee,
cause I know he hurt his knee and then
the room was where he got it operated on
and then heard it again
like came back too quickly.
Really.
You know I,
I had seen him maybe two
months ago and you know,
speaking to some of
his management as well.
I mean they believe he's
going to be back soon.
Right around,
I think the time that pedis is gonna
Fight dos Anjos so he'll be waiting in the
wings,
you know,
quickly he,
I think he's even complained that to sign.
Just leaving it in the shot.
Yeah,
he is complaining that,
but he's not ready to say,
I mean you can't train right now.
No.
And if he does,
fuck is knee,
but probably just fucking duct tape it
together and get back in there anyway.
We're saying you don't want
to ruin your career to come,
you know,
take your time.
And the one crazy thing is though,
if if aunt,
cause it's not a walk in the park for
pedes to beat Anjos does not just as
dangerous and doesn't just wrestling
look really good against Nate Diaz,
but pennys he's a sniper.
He just needs one shot.
That's how scary that kid is.
I mean he,
you know,
he can go into a fight and barely
messes hair and only hit you once.
He also has a style that's based on
not like there's a style of kicking and
punching that a lot of these guys do.
That's Moy Thai style where there's a
step and then a kick a step and then a
kick and pedis has got that
taekwondo thing where he's,
he's standing there and he
just throws it Zero Telegraph,
Zero Telegraph with o power and it's
tough to fuck with if you watch him like
the head kick that he landed on,
Joe Lozan,
here's it comes out of nowhere.
The one he landed on Donald's Roni,
it comes out of nowhere.
And so Ronnie's a fucking ex all
Stryker and he's in phenomenal.
That kid naturally has incredible cardio.
We would go do these sand dunes
at Jackson's and add altitude.
These things are are 60
to 70 meter high or or,
or,
or length sand dunes that,
that are a steep incline to where the
sand falls and you have to crawl up with
all force.
He glides up to this thing,
smokes everybody.
Even when he's not in,
in premier shape to kick him
in the body and Kayo him.
I mean,
you've got a bruise deep,
deep,
deep on the,
I call them soul kicks.
You kick a dude so hard,
you see that.
You see the shit face and the soul
just come sneaking right out the mouth.
You know,
that's what happens.
There's nothing.
You can do those liver shots,
man.
Then not like anything anybody could
describe unless you've been hit like that.
Oh,
it's this weird thing where your body
just stops working and it's war as sucks
because you're helpless and you're,
but you're conscious,
so you're forced to watch the dude
kick your ass while you're helpless.
You can't do anything to stop,
especially in MMA and boxing.
At least you'd go down and the,
you know the countdowns,
like Oscar de la Hoya versus
Bernard Hopkins and he was
the only time we've ever
seen del La Jolla gets stopped like that.
But Bernard just fucking
hooked him right in that lever.
And you see his whole body just,
it's the weirdest thing man.
And sometimes you could play it off,
you know,
you get hit and you can kind of move
with it and like a guy doesn't know.
But then there's times where you get hit
and like it doesn't the cro cop versus
heath herring,
you ever see that?
Yes.
There's a fucking photograph online
CV would find this photo of Cro,
cop's Shin buried halfway
into he heath herrings body.
And this is when cro
cop was fucking Croak.
Yeah.
When he was on his run towards the title
and he hit heath herring with this at
my house,
I couldn't breathe.
I was watching it at home and I was like,
look,
look at that fucking kick.
Oh my God,
Dude.
That's like taking your,
your lungs,
kidneys and intestines and just,
I mean smushing them all
together for a brief second.
I mean that is disgusting.
And look,
his foot is pulled back so you know,
it's all shin bone and you know
how god Damn Hard Mirko kicks.
That is the most horrific
looking body shot I've ever seen.
Anybody take in a photograph,
did it?
I mean you don't see,
you see that and like car wrecks.
Yeah,
that's exactly what it looks like.
It looks like you got,
he looks like he was on a motorcycle and
he crashed into a telephone pole that
was on the back of a pickup truck.
You know,
just boom.
His whole body is mat
that puts any picture.
I've got a couple of pictures where I'm
taking shots and that puts everything I
had to shame.
I feel,
I feel like a chump just looking at it.
And Dad is the liver kick.
That is the liver kick.
That's all.
I mean it's a rough
your heart and separate.
It's everything.
Anything internal,
it's over.
The ribs are probably broken.
Probably broke some ribs.
And I'd like to talk to heath about that.
Yeah.
Jesus fucking Christ and,
and you know,
we saw that with Maci
diverse Dalloway doll.
I mean it,
you know,
Dalloway has done such a
fantastic job of finally,
you know,
reaching his potential and
showcase her that he does.
And it's so hard for fighters cause
you want to at least go out there and
showcase your skills and similar
to pedes but a different style,
you know,
taekwondo and now you're looking at at
karate and a guy who no telegraph sends
it right underneath the elbow.
Your garden pinpoint accuracy
in the fight is over.
I called that fight.
It's sounded like someone took a two by
four and just smacked it off this table
and it echoed throughout the stadium.
Yeah,
I watched that and as soon as I saw
the look on his face like oh this is
probably over done.
Yeah he's got that.
And he hit him with his Shin
and his instep at the same time.
I mean in step kicks,
like a lot of people think that like the
foot area is like not as effective in,
it's not as hard,
but God damn it's hard
enough to knock you out.
I mean it's still a God damn bone.
You can kick some of the
pretty hard this Thai,
the Thai style,
you could deliver a bit more power,
but it does take a little
more time to get there.
And you know,
some of them depending on the athlete too,
you know where I kicked harder
more from a a Thai style stance,
but I don't have the flexibility
of a guy like an Anthony Pettis.
Right.
And,
and you know,
what are,
what are their level,
their muscle levers like two in their
hips and what's their fast twitch muscle
fibers.
Like,
you know,
you can pick different styles,
but sometimes you get the athletes who
did train the perfect styles for their
body style,
their genetics.
And that's where you get the Anthony
Pettis and the Leo to Machida's who,
who have the,
the perfect genetic
structure for that as well.
Well,
there's also the speed that you
develop when you do it your whole life.
That's almost,
you almost can't replicate it by starting
in your 20s or your thirties and you
learning martial arts.
You know,
we'd coming from a wrestling
background and learning how to kick,
you're probably never going to be able
to collect and Cheetah or luck pedis,
you know,
they have this ridiculous speed.
It's just,
it's this weird thing that they can
do to their body because their body
developed doing that.
I mean,
they went through maturity doing that.
Their muscles literally grew
onto their bones throwing kicks.
Yeah.
I mean,
lifelong martial arts.
He,
you didn't win when I was
still fighting the UFC.
You still had a handful
of guys that were like me.
I mean,
I didn't even start thinking
about doing this till 26.
Never had a first real
lesson till I was 27.
That's so crazy.
And so,
um,
I mean,
now you got these guys
like Rory Macdonald,
they grew up doing it.
You're a GSP was one of the first and
he was a lifelong martial artists and
that's where your,
you know,
Michael Bisman was a lifelong martial
artist and now you're getting guys that
are even higher level athletes,
not necessarily GSP,
but higher level athletes that are
lifelong martial artists coming into this
sport.
And I consider wrestlers
lifelong martial artist as well.
You know,
when you're doing that shit
since you're five years old,
you know you are,
I mean to me wrestling's a martial arts,
one of the best in the war in the world.
Yeah.
One of them.
I think the most important,
if you're a really good wrestle,
you dictate where the fight takes place.
Absolutely.
But the,
some wrestlers never
develop that strength.
It's almost like their body's not designed
to strike like a good example with
all due respect is Matt,
who was one of the fucking
toughest guys ever fight in MMA.
It was a fantastic grappler.
Well I think he wants silver,
silver,
silver looks fucking great wrestler.
I mean you got got ahold
of you manhandled people,
but his striking was always
fairly awkward on his feet.
Never developed,
like,
you know,
you're never going to mistake
him for Anderson Silva.
Never feet.
And it probably never
wasn't available to them.
I mean,
how much scar tissue they build up in
their hips and their shoulders from years
and years of wrestling,
which I know for me coming from
football and the Marine Corps,
you know,
even now,
I mean,
you,
you're supposed to be able to
touch one hand behind your head,
the other hand behind your back,
you feel to meet your fingers
in between your shoulder blades.
I mean,
I've got like 2 million.
Yeah,
I've got like two feet.
I'm work.
We give it a shot.
Let's see what you can do.
One Hand behind the head sore,
right shoulder.
So I can't do it one way.
I can do it like this canyon.
Yeah.
All right.
Well,
I mean,
a lot of those guys probably can,
I'm almost embarrassed to show mine.
Wow,
that's crazy,
dude.
That's all I got.
It's,
I mean,
but that's a lot of,
you have a lot of muscle to,
isn't that?
Yeah.
I've separated both shoulders,
the AC joints a couple of times each.
And,
um,
you know,
a hump in with,
with big packs all the
time in the military,
shit built up scar tissue all the time.
Oh for sure.
And then grappling is
the worst off shoulders,
knees and necks and backs.
And after awhile it's everybody's
playing demolition derby.
After awhile,
you know,
frames get bent fucking,
things blow out.
That's it,
eh?
Yeah.
And you see that's where you got to get
the crafty old veterans who come out
there and pull off some sick moves and
have their experience to win fights and
or they ride off into the sunset.
Well again with Nogueira the word is
that no care needs like an hour to get
ready just to train.
Like he has a guy who travels with him
and the guy does massage and stretches
him and does all this shit and like
literally can't train unless he does this
hour long regimen before he gets in there.
Wow.
Yeah.
I mean there's just,
there's so much your body can take,
you know,
and so many guys have fucking fuse
joints or fused up disks rather.
Um,
some,
some guys are getting
artificial discs put in there.
Apparently they're getting
way better at that.
I know.
Braulio esteem,
Osa,
worldclass Jujitsu,
black belt.
He has,
um,
an artificial disc in his neck that
somehow or another it rotates and moves.
Well.
It's like,
it's something they do in Europe and I
guess they're starting to do it here in
America.
You know,
who had one,
he had an artificial disc putting his
neck is the fuck is named Freddie Prinze
jr the uh,
the actor,
he just doing Jujitsu and uh,
I mean he's really doing Jujitsu likes,
you know,
he's,
he's doing a lot of rolling and apparently
he just had neck surgery and he's
showing all these a photos of the scar
and the neck surgery and you know,
and uh,
he trains down with Henna and here on,
and those guys down in Torrance.
And I asked him about [inaudible].
He said,
yeah,
he's training.
He trains hard.
He says he's a legit blue belt.
No Kid.
Yeah.
And
isn't that goes Foxville?
No,
I mean,
it happened.
It happens.
This port for sure.
And you know,
it's interesting because when,
as we talk about this and we,
and we've talked a lot
about the damage guys,
cause we've gone through
all the various techniques.
You know,
after you had,
you know,
a discussion with Brendan Schaub,
a lot of people came out
and they started saying,
hey,
should we feel bad for
talking about this sport?
And I,
and I've heard that conversation again,
you know,
at what point should we feel
guilty for watching guys?
We know our aging fighters.
And you know,
you could do the same thing with football.
You could certainly do the same
thing in the military where there's,
there's a lot of traumatic brain injuries
taking place in the military as well.
One thing that,
that I think people forget and that I
think people need to understand that it's,
it's not to excuse anything or
take away from the conversation.
It's,
it's a little bit of a mitigation.
The,
the men and women who do sports like this,
if you take it away from them,
they're going to find it elsewhere.
I mean it's,
it's a need.
You know,
for a guy like me had I not
found mixed martial arts,
I was going to find something.
There's,
there's like there's drive inside us to
do something extreme that makes people
raise their eyebrows and say,
are you sure you want it?
You really are going to do that.
They have that,
that desire and,
and it's just a personality trait.
I mean if,
if mixed martial arts didn't exist,
I mean look at cowboy Cerrone,
the things he does to,
to fill that hole in his life and
you're going to get a lot of guys,
that's why guys don't want to retire.
It's just part of who they are.
We all know the risks.
We all know everything we're up against.
We still sign the contract.
And so it's important to remind them
that if you know for people that are anti
this and anti that,
you know,
we're going to do something
like that anyways,
we're going to find something else to do.
And at some point we've got to be
accountable for her own actions.
Well,
there's a wide variety of human beings
is always going to be sedentary.
People that sit in their couch is going
to be people who want fucking rock climb
with no ropes.
It's just like you ever
see that Alex Honnold guy,
the the free climber Guy,
Jesus Christ,
we had him on the podcast.
He's the most mellow,
laid back,
super sweet guy,
great to talk to,
but this fucking guy,
he not only does he climb these insane
peaks that people get scared to climb
with ropes.
He does it with no ropes.
He also takes paths that no
one has ever done before.
He takes his fucking crazy pass that
have never been accomplished by anyone,
and he does it with no fucking rope.
He said,
he look at,
he goes,
not just straight up,
he goes at an angle the wrong way.
Like he goes at an angle like 15
degrees towards him and he climbs.
Look at Dutch.
I mean that's,
that's him with ropes.
You could see a rope there,
but there's,
there's video of him
climbing this one air.
Look at that right there.
That's no fucking rope.
He's got no rope there and he's
got no road and he is incredible.
He is like,
what,
1,002 thousand feet
over the fucking ground.
Holy Christ.
And the crazy,
I mean there's,
there's,
there's nobody around them
that I see pushing him.
No.
You know,
in terms,
hey,
like I have
to do this.
Like you'll see other
people that'll do extreme,
amazing things,
but there's,
there's people around them to make them
feel more comfortable while doing it.
You're on your own.
That's incredible.
Yeah.
He lives in his fucking van.
He has a van,
he sleeps in his van.
He's got his little boxes for
underwear and toothpaste and shit.
And he just sleeps in his van and climbs
all the time is as he found a way to
monetize them.
And as he make any money
for climbing and stuff,
at least,
I don't know.
I mean,
I would like to help the guy,
but you know,
there's the people that
are in that industry,
quote unquote,
the,
the free climbing world.
They're terrified of him
because they're like,
well,
this guy,
it's just,
it's,
I mean,
there was an interview that I watched on
one of those major shows where I found
out about him where they said,
look,
it's not a matter of
if he's going to fall,
it's a matter of when is he going to fall.
You know,
he does.
He disagrees.
He says,
I know what I'm doing.
Uh,
every time I do this,
I,
I plot my strategy.
I figure out what path I'm going to take.
He does it with ropes first.
He maps it all out and
as he's mapping it out,
he's climbing up and he's seeing,
okay,
well what can I do here?
But even told me on the podcast one time,
he was doing one of these fucking
climbs and he started the climb,
got like,
you know,
x amount of feet up and
realize you forgot his powder.
So you know,
they,
they put that powder to keep
their fingers are slipping.
I don't even lift weights
without fucking powder.
You know,
I don't even do kettle
bells without this shit.
This guy's climbing 5,000 or so.
I'm a homeowner,
so how many fucking fee to
be it will be is right here.
Like look at that.
And that's an incredible,
he's insane.
But he did it without fucking powder.
God halfway up ran into some
other climbers who couldn't
believe he didn't have
any ropes.
They'll like,
you're just climbing.
They gave him a powder bag and then he
finished the rest of the climb and then
left the powder bag at the top for them.
I love the public,
a heart monitor on him.
If you know something
that would like show,
you know,
what's his heart rate at when he does
this and it's probably something like
disgustingly low.
Yeah,
but he says he,
it says it's really mellow.
He says,
if your heart gets,
if,
if there's a moment where
your heart's racing,
you're probably fucked.
Like you probably made a really,
really,
really terrible mistake,
but you're,
you know,
your point is that there's
guys that are like that.
I mean,
what is more dangerous is
fighting more dangerous and that,
well it depends right now fighting's
more dangerous until he falls,
then that's way more far more.
But there's going to be,
there's,
there's people that have,
the reason why we have human
beings in 2015 is because there's,
there's a genetic predisposition
that some folks have to taking risks,
exploring new lands,
getting in boats,
going across the,
the ocean fighting and battles,
conquering new new environments.
I mean,
this a part of being a human.
There's a drive that some people have
and it sort of speaks to this idea that
everyone has a role in this
crazy dance that is life.
And without each one of us,
it would never work.
And that all of us,
somehow or another,
are integrated as this one gigantic
super organism and we're moving humanity
towards some ultimate goal.
But without these risk takers,
without warriors,
without people that are willing to
climb fucking rocks and all that,
it's a part of who we are.
Absolute.
And you can't,
you know,
I've heard people say like mixed
martial arts should be illegal.
I'm like,
Whoa,
stop,
stop.
You can't nerf the fucking world.
You're going to die no matter what.
Yeah,
if you don't get head kicked,
you're still going to die.
Absolutely.
And you know,
there,
there's,
there's a lot of mitigating factors,
but the end of the day,
you know,
every fighter chooses to do this,
it's on them to do it.
And,
and you know,
Gosh,
football is way worse.
You know,
I called one season of college football.
There were two games where I saw guys,
you know,
Tibias break in half in one game.
The Amaanah headshots you take if you're
a defense or offensive linemen in those
games.
When I played football with Gi,
graduated from the Naval Academy and Oh
three we didn't have anybody checking if
we had any concussions.
I was,
they've,
since then they have a band
having a wedge on kickoff return.
I was the wedge breaker on kickoff team.
So I would take a couple of a Phaedra
and I would sprint all the way down field
and I'd run rate into four dudes sitting
right next to each other from Notre
Dame.
I don't stand a chance against these guys.
I just got to be a sacrificial
lamb to bust this thing up.
Right.
You know,
I have no idea if I've got
a concussion doing that.
I know it didn't feel good.
What?
How does the federal help?
I,
who knows?
It gets your heartbeat and real fast.
We thought it's just placebo.
Oh,
a federal is like a stimulant.
Yeah.
Remember they dal,
it's like a ton of caffeine,
right?
They banded shortly.
If we couldn't even use it anymore,
I think my senior year was banned.
It was tooken out.
All supplements.
So jujitsu class wants.
After I took a couple of rip fuels and
I almost had a fucking heart attack.
Do you remember that?
I remember riff fuels,
that shit used to be literally used to
be able to go to GNC and buy crank it.
You can get it like sands,
Sam's club.
It was fucking crank.
I mean it was,
your heart would be and you feel like
you could fucking run through a wall.
It was so retarded
that that stuff was
completely legal is a very,
very bizarre thing that,
I mean if you look at the 2003 when
you're talking about when you're playing
football,
you look at that and you
look at the reality of today.
Well what are you showing me here,
Jamie?
Oh No,
I didn't see it.
You didn't tell him you're
going to show me anything.
He's got the straw.
Oh my God,
you just flew through the air
and that'll ruin your day.
Oh Dude,
they're going to look at them.
Yeah.
Paleo
and then it collapses
and everybody cheers.
And back then,
I mean there was no protocol.
It's like when I played,
I played six years of Pop Warner football
and one of the drills we do for our
tackling drills two times a week,
we'd line up the whole team in one line,
the first guy to get the ball,
get to run through each guy individually.
One on one,
just run,
hit Ron.
Hey
run hop Warner's little kids.
We've got a bunch of dads are just
guys from the neighborhood that Vaughn,
I mean they don't know
anything about football.
I don't know anything.
It's been an incredible that human
beings have been around for thousands and
thousands and thousands of years.
And it was 2003 that's
only 12 fucking years ago.
Nobody knew that you were
getting concussions all the time.
And this could be bad.
Oh yeah.
That doesn't seem to make any sense.
Does it doesn't.
But you know,
it's funny,
I mean it opens up a whole other door.
We are still so prime
for as advanced as we are technologically.
When you look at what's taking
place in the world right now and,
and how easy it still is
for people that take lives.
You know,
I've seen studies on chimpanzees with aid,
they have murderer with
chimps and things like that.
And so some scientists will argue
that it's kind of predetermined in our
genetics and in our DNA that,
you know,
we're aggressive,
we're going to do things like this.
But I mean there's still a lot of primal
qualities that we have in humanity.
I mean,
you look at what took place
in France today when I'm so,
so in France,
three guys who,
who are expected to be
Muslim because they were,
they were chanting Muslim
chants and they went in,
they did an attack on a French
magazine that does frequent cartoons,
um,
you know,
basically making fun
of the Muslim religion.
And so these guys attacked at separate
everybody and executed I believe nine
people.
And then on the way out til
killed two more police officers.
And,
and these three men,
you know,
they,
they think they,
they haven't released a
lot of information on them,
but they went in there like
they were trained military.
It didn't look like your average,
you know,
typical terrorist who
got recruited online,
found a gun and wit and shoot somebody.
It wasn't the,
uh,
the two brothers who made
a pot bomb up in Boston.
These dudes knew what they were doing.
Um,
you know,
and,
and it's huge news to couple with that.
You know,
it's getting less news.
I think there was a,
a suicide bomb in Yemen
that killed 30 people.
This is incredible.
[inaudible] parachuting.
Suspects are still at large,
two of them are still at large,
and this was all over making
fun of a fucking religion.
That's incredible,
man.
They,
they,
in fact,
one of them,
I think they showed one of the,
one of the cartoons and the
main cartoonists day day,
they knew her by name.
They knew people by name separate
and they made sure she was killed.
Um,
but she even did one on Mohamed.
Okay.
And so what a crazy religion where
you can't even draw their guy.
I mean,
you could,
you could have,
I mean,
Sam Kinison who used to be a preacher,
had Jesus Christ,
jokes about him getting
nailed to the cross.
I mean,
he had jokes about Jesus Christ,
about his wife,
you know,
saying he's a loser and you're
hanging out with the 12 apostles,
they're losers.
You're friends are losers.
He mocked,
openly mocked this religion that,
you know,
he used to be a part of no repercussions.
You draw Muhammad just
drawn and you're fucking,
you know,
your suspect or you're a
subject to this kind of shit.
It's incredible.
It's,
uh,
you know,
it,
it never in my life,
and obviously I haven't been everywhere,
so I'm pretty well traveled.
I've just,
I've never been anywhere like my
time in the Middle East where,
where I've seen not everybody,
but certain people value
human life so little,
so little.
And it's a really hard thing to comprehend
when you're there and you try with a
language barrier to understand it more.
And the only thing I was
able to conclude was that,
you know,
this certain population
has been so accustomed to
violence for so many centuries
that uh,
their endurance for it is so much
greater than Western civilization.
And,
and that is,
that is part of the problem with us
getting involved in conflicts over there
where look,
you know,
they're going to replenish their forces
every time someone turns 16 they're
going to join the ranks
or whatever age it may be.
Whereas,
you know,
here,
um,
we're not able to do that,
you know,
are,
in order to be a son who had a great point
or to be successful military campaign
need three things.
You need the people,
you need the government and you
need the military without all three
synchronized,
you will not be successful.
If you lose one of them,
it's out.
And you could see Vietnam,
you could see Iraq.
When the people get disgusted,
then it becomes a problem and it's
going to pull back the government.
And then you know,
the military is going to pull back.
And really you're going
to see us get outlasted.
Now.
I'm not making the argument
that we belonged and you know,
that's a whole other bag
of worms we can get there.
But you know,
over there,
they know we're setting dates
for when we're going to withdraw.
I mean,
they're just so much more
use to violence that,
that not,
and I shouldn't generalize everybody,
but,
but the,
the,
the units,
you know,
I k al-Qaida Taliban,
uh,
they're so used to violence that
they can stomach it and they're just,
it's just the way they've always lived.
Well,
it's what you were saying about
God's like a beep number Grumet off.
Growing up in Dagestan and growing up
in these really harsh environments,
it,
they,
they become tougher.
People were so used to a certain easy
way of life that these folks have this
much more intense,
much more dangerous environment that
they live in and that is normal to them.
And when people grow up
in certain environments,
that becomes how they live.
And we're adaptable as hell.
Well,
yeah,
I mean,
you look at one of them,
one of the most disturbing
when when I try to explain,
because people will forget,
um,
or they'll take for granted,
I should say how evil,
uh,
or,
or what kind of evil
does exist in the world.
And,
and people will talk
about Isis and you know,
uh,
you know,
Ben Affleck made a comment,
they couldn't even fill
a baseball stadium,
you know,
a Aa be at ball stadium
or something like that.
They're not a threat.
People will take for granted,
you know,
that the type of evil that
does exist in the world,
and it's not just obviously
in the Muslim culture.
I just,
you know,
as an example,
it exists.
It exists plenty in Africa
as well in certain areas.
But one video all tell people,
you know,
checkout,
and it's not for everybody.
But if you look at a video
of the [inaudible] massacre,
which,
which happened in
Dagestan where Chechnyan,
uh,
rebels massacred Russian soldiers and
they basically one by one while they're
alive,
behead them where it takes a long
enemy and the video is disgusting.
I don't recommend anybody here
who's listening this go watch it.
This is when I get into intense debate
with people that I know are mature enough
to handle it in,
in,
or trying to understand certain things.
I'll recommend you if you want
to understand this a little bit,
take a look at this.
I mean,
it's hard to watch to understand that
that exists and to imagine that a human
being is capable not
only of doing it once,
but repeatedly and talking casually like
we are right now while they're doing
it.
While someone's squirms on
the ground being decapitated,
that takes something inside
that that is sickening,
that is frightening.
And it exists throughout human history.
It does.
It's a quality that solutely does.
Human beings can tap into and
almost in a way that animals can't,
it's almost in the,
the,
the mind has the,
the human mind has this
ability to compartmentalize
and to rationalize and to be
capable of things that
even animals aren't,
aren't capable of doing
animals killed to eat.
Or occasionally the intelligent
animals like chimpanzees,
you know,
they'll,
they'll kill to protect environments or
proper overthrow overthrow the alpha.
Yeah.
But what these,
these are,
this is a different thing.
I mean this is,
this is ritualized killing.
This is,
this is killing on a level that
the justification of that is,
is it's hard to comprehend for the
average person that lives in a nice,
you know,
community and it goes to the supermarket
and likes to go to a restaurant and
order a glass of wine,
clink glasses.
And this is like,
well,
I support war.
You know what war is?
They have no idea.
Yeah,
no idea.
I mean,
and it's not just,
you know,
I certainly don't want the people at home
to think we're generalizing the Middle
East.
I mean you can go to Rwanda and
look at what took places or one,
look what takes place in
Sudan every single day.
You know,
and it's sad cause you
talked about how we're this,
this,
a global race of beings at all
have a place at the table to,
to progress ourselves.
Yet there's still so many things,
you know,
that show that we are still very primal.
Well,
there's areas of the world that
just have not caught up yet.
There's areas of the world that give
us a window into the past would,
it must've been like to
live thousands of years ago.
When you hear about all these barbaric
events that happened in human history
that most people just
like to look at and go,
oh,
those were the dark ages.
This was,
you know,
back in Gingiss cons day.
This was backward.
Alexander the Great was around,
no,
no.
It's the fucking Congo doesn't 15.
If you were there right now in,
in,
in one of those areas where warlords or
tearing into villages and machete and
people's to death,
you would watch exactly what,
what would have happened
a thousand years ago,
10,000 years ago.
I mean,
the only difference is these people have
clothes that were made in a factory and
machetes that were made
in a factory and guns.
Yeah.
Other than that,
it's human barbarism.
Absolutely.
And it's a,
it's,
it's very disconcerting for a
lot of people because you know,
you,
when a child,
especially when I was a kid,
I'm 47 and when I was,
um,
I don't know how old I was,
I was probably like nine or something,
maybe 10 when the Vietnam war ended.
I don't know what,
but I was living in California
and I remember it was on TV.
It was on the news where America
is pulling out of the Vietnam bar.
And I remember thinking
it was a little kid.
Well,
this is great.
Glad we figured out that war is bad
and we're never going to do this again
because everybody really
hates war and we're moving on.
I remember having this idea in my mind
as a child that we are evolving past war
and this is good that I grew up in a day,
you know,
cause I talked to,
uh,
my Stepdad,
you know,
he was worried about getting
drafted and never did.
And there's people in
my neighborhood that,
uh,
had been to Vietnam and I talked to
them about it and everybody was almost
unanimous that we shouldn't have
been there and the war is bad.
And then I was a kid.
I was maybe 21 when we went
into the first Gulf War.
And I remember watching on TV
with my roommate and me and my,
uh,
my friend Jimmy,
my roommate,
we were like,
holy fucking shit.
We're doing it again.
Couldn't believe.
But it was that long stretch that
America had not been in like a real quote
unquote war.
We had gone through some military actions,
a lot of covert shit,
a lot of things that weren't
in the news and daily basis.
And so people weren't really aware of how
the world works and how much bloodshed
is required in order to
keep peace in certain areas.
And then all of a sudden it's on again.
Yeah.
I remember thinking,
I can't believe this.
You know,
and it's interesting too because you know,
people,
people don't bring this up off.
And could you imagine
what would happen if,
if our navy was so downsize that
they no longer patrol the waters?
What,
what would oil prices be like?
Shipping link is piracy is still a
problem and we ended up doing most of,
or ma,
we do a lot of policing,
you know,
out there in the seas with,
with constant appointments for our navy.
And uh,
it's,
it's crazy,
but the world,
you know,
and,
and you know,
as in,
sorry,
I got into discussion with a,
with a Harvard Law Grad today about it.
You know,
what came first?
The chicken or the egg,
you know,
had we not gone to them in the Middle
East and interfered with that have
prevented a lot of the terrorist
attacks that we've taken place.
You know?
And she threw that out there and I said,
well,
you know,
this attack happened in France.
How much involvement is France
had in Iraq and Afghanistan?
You know,
and so it's hard to ever
comprehend at this point,
but there,
there is a lot of violence in the world
and there's a hatred that we can't
comprehend.
Like the way that the al Qaeda in Iraq,
when I was there,
hated us.
We in America could never
comprehend that kind of hatred.
We don't even know what it's like.
I didn't know what it was like.
I couldn't have met.
I mean to the point where you are
willing to not only try to kill me,
but you'll kill innocent children just
to get at me and have no issues doing it.
You'll repeatedly tried to do that.
That what that does to the mind,
you know,
when people will look at post traumatic
stress and in it the is not meant to,
to,
to handle all of that.
Especially when it's a young kid.
You know,
who's 18,
19 years old who most likely came from,
you know,
a pretty poor background.
That's the reason they decided to enlist
in the military during a time of two
wars.
So it,
it's,
it's an unbelievable debate and discussion
that's going to take place for years
and we'll never know.
We'll never fully know
because of course there,
there's so much politics at play
with it as well that clouds the,
the overall analysis of
what truly takes place.
Um,
and,
and you know,
that goes into a whole
lot of discussion on how,
you know,
certain policies are made,
based on political timelines,
vice when they're actually needed.
It's also one of the,
the true horrors about drones that is
constantly up for debate because drones
are so nonspecific.
There's so many people that have been
killed by drones that were absolutely
innocent.
A lot of them children,
a lot of them women,
a lot of them completely,
you know,
civilians and that a lot of people
on the other side would say,
well,
what you're talking about these horrific
things they're done by the United
States,
but they're done in this weird way with
a robot that flies in the sky and shoots
missiles.
It's,
it's sterilized in the sense
that it's not like the,
you know,
these,
uh,
these Russians,
you know,
killing Chechnyan rebels or Chechen
rebels killing Russians with a knife.
It's,
it's,
it's sterilized in,
in the sense that no one has
to get blood on their hands.
They're you using a remote control.
They're watching a monitor,
the pressing a button,
but the same result that's taking place.
Certainly.
And I mean it,
the,
the end result is,
is,
is human life has been,
has been terminated.
Did you,
when you enlisted and you went over,
was this a part of like sort of the same
drive that lead that lead you to be a
fighter?
You know,
I think so.
for me,
I was in high school at the time and
I was getting recruited by a bunch of
different schools to play football and
I kind of already had a sense that,
that I really would like to
attend a military academy.
But then,
um,
I also started getting heavily recruited
by a lot of Ivy League schools.
And in my education mattered,
I looked at some of the graduation
rate to some of the other,
you know,
Division One AA schools recruit me in
a West Virginia and Maryland and the
graduation rates were low.
And I,
I knew,
look,
I'm not going to go play
professional football.
I need to go somewhere.
I'm going to get education.
And the Naval Academy was free.
You don't get a full,
so you don't get a scholarship
to an ivy league school.
So my mom was a home health nurse,
isn't gonna be able to
afford to send me to Yale,
even with the financial aid.
So I went to the Naval Academy and also
I've always been a pretty intense guy
who took things more seriously
maybe than they need to be taken.
And so I thought,
look,
this is a place I'm going to go and
I'm going to get along with the people
better.
But when I was there initially
it was time of peace.
You graduated,
you either went in the navy or the
Marine Corps and you would deploy,
you'd go on a boat,
you'd float around a bunch of
cities for six to seven months,
have a good time,
then come home,
then maybe do one more,
then moved to a different duty station.
It wasn't the same when I was a junior
is when nine 11 happened and shit changed
forever.
It was never the same.
And then the,
the second Iraq war,
it actually started when I was a senior.
So I had friends that were in the,
you know,
initial wave and the second Iraq
war that I played football with.
Um,
you know,
before I'd even graduated.
So you didn't necessarily
sign up to go to war,
you signed up because you felt like those
were people that you would relate to
more.
Yeah.
But I mean,
at the same time I bought
into the whole package,
you know,
I wanted to serve my country.
I knew,
look,
you know,
um,
inside I felt like I was a warrior at
the time and this is where I belong and
this is where,
you know,
my,
my leadership skills can be honed and I
can develop and this is where I should
be.
When the war started,
you know,
I could have easily chosen to go,
I could have gone surface warfare and
been on a boat and been pretty much away
from the fight.
You know,
I chose to go marine corps,
chose to go infantry,
you know,
and chose to be there where I
already had friends that were there.
You know,
there was no way I wasn't going to
be a guy who served at that time.
What was it that drew
you into doing infantry?
What was it like?
What,
when you decided,
when you made that commitment,
like what was,
what was on your mind?
You know,
I couldn't see any other choice.
I would feel guilty had I not,
you know,
before I had ever even gone
infantry officer school,
um,
Ronnie Winchester who played offensive
tackle first when I was a sophomore,
he was killed.
Um,
and then while I was in
infant officer course,
a guy at graduate,
JP blacksmith,
he was killed in Fallujah.
So,
I mean,
there was a time period there for several
years where when guys call that we
hadn't heard from in a while,
we almost didn't want
to pick up the phone.
You know,
it was,
it was really,
it was a really difficult time.
Um,
but,
but that's,
that's war.
I mean,
it's,
it's ugly.
It's,
it sucks.
There's,
there's nothing fun about it.
And,
and,
you know,
a pet peeve of mine is a lot of
other cultures and even sometimes,
you know,
in our own,
they make these assumptions about
the men and women that go to war.
You know,
I actually got asked in inline
to a way in when I was in Japan,
and I'm going to name the fighter
because I don't want to insult anybody.
He looks at me and says,
while we're waiting,
we're about to go wham.
He's like,
Brian,
you know,
how do you justify going to Iraq and
just killing generations of people?
And I was like,
well,
I think you're a little misinformed
and I'm certainly willing to have that
discussion with you.
Um,
but I don't think now's
the appropriate time.
He's like,
well,
I'm fucking nosy.
So that's exact quote.
I'm nosy.
So you know,
let's,
uh,
I'm asking about it.
And so,
you know,
I mean,
it's the,
the,
the happiest moments of,
you know,
my specialty,
my second tour,
there were two schools in our area of
operations that never had school because
if the teachers taught they'd be killed,
I'll kinda would kill them immediately
if they taught those students.
And this area had never
been patrolled before.
So we started patrolling.
We started securing it five
months into our deployment.
We had the areas so secure that these
kids were able to go to school again.
And that was a really proud day.
I mean it wasn't,
it's not what a lot of people think where,
you know,
we go over there and all
we want to do is kill,
kill,
kill.
I mean 90% I mean you don't even see
the enemy in these kinds of wars.
It's snipers.
It's Ibds,
it's unseen enemies.
You're walking the streets trying to help
these people getting blown up and shot
at,
you know,
where you came and tell
where it's coming from.
[inaudible] and most of the
scenarios and really what we found,
because the doctrine for this kind of
war was never written in the military had
to adapt to it and we had to create
this new counterinsurgency warfare.
The key was the people,
whoever owned the trust of the people,
one the conflict because the people,
if they trusted you would then give you
the Intel necessary to find out where
I'll kite is coming in from
and who they're influencing,
who they're using,
their who their informants are,
how to catch them,
what time you can catch him,
and that was the main factor.
By month six over there,
we were literally getting names and full
descriptions of who was coming in and
we had snatched up 30 guys in a month.
You know,
it was because the people at that
point trusted us and believed,
hey,
you know what,
the,
these guys are helping us.
They're injecting money into our economy,
helping us reopen the shops.
They're securing the school
so the kids can go to school.
They're helping to clean up the garbage.
They're really here to help.
And that's what made
the biggest difference.
It was more shaking
hands than it ever was,
pulling triggers,
yet I can't tell you how many comments,
you know,
the biggest hatred all received,
both social media and even just
in the fight world in general,
from mostly foreign culture,
sometimes even ours.
And America is all get called a murderer.
And look,
I don't,
I don't take it personally
because I know the truth.
Obviously I'm secure in that,
but there's a lot of
misinformation out there.
That's,
um,
that's the main representation,
of,
of people that go to war
is that you're over there.
You're invading this country.
You never hear that you're,
you're getting the support of the
people and that that's how you win those
fights.
That's how you win those battles.
You,
you always hear like we're
invading in this country.
They don't want us there.
You're dealing with a Muslim country.
But even in these is consciousness.
These Islamic countries,
these people that practice the Islamic
religion are still against these radical
fundamentalist people that are throwing
acid in the face of the children that
are trying to go to school and trying
to keep women from driving cars and all
the crazy shit that we keep hearing about.
So how much conflict is there
like inter religion conflict?
I mean it seems like it must be,
it must be very difficult for these
people in this as Islamic country to take
trust in these soldiers
that come over from America.
Oh absolutely.
Especially when you first get there
and you go to an area that's never been
patrol before,
you know,
in,
in any,
you know,
any screw up that takes place.
You know,
if,
uh,
if something happens and
there is collateral damage,
if there you do get into a firefight,
the enemy only attacks you when
you're surrounded by civilians.
And so if something bad does happen,
it will set you back.
Weeks,
months could even be
years in the conflict.
And so,
and that goes against the maybe the 350
positive things that that took place at
that time.
But there were a lot of people,
at least,
you know,
I can speak from my perspective and the
two area of operations I operate in,
there are a lot of people
that wanted us to be there.
There were a lot of people
that had smartphones in a
lot of people that saw how
people live in other civilizations.
And we're fed up with
having corrupt governments,
you know,
that,
that word that we're basically taking
from them at all times and using them as
pawns and they wanted to
live that kind of life.
And they get angry when these extremist
groups set back their religion.
And,
and even just their culture,
you know,
when you see something like
what happened in Paris,
you know,
we talked about that,
that's going to bring
back everybody saying,
Hey,
you know,
uh,
the entire Islam religion
is completely evil.
You know,
you're going to get bill Maher out
there saying it again and again.
And again,
there are people in the Muslim
religion that don't believe like that.
They don't believe in that
and they're not extremist,
but it's,
it's this,
it's this horrible conflict that
we're dealing with right now.
Um,
and like so many others were not
capable of having good open discussion.
You get someone who believes in this
ideology all the way at the far end of the
table.
Then you get the other
person who believes is here.
And for some reason,
both of them think they're 100% right,
which is absolute insanity.
I mean,
what argument have you ever
been in where you're 100% right?
Yeah.
Well,
especially when it comes
to something like religion,
you know,
and the Islamic religion in general,
it's such as such an old
religion and it's got so many,
when you look at so many interpretations.
Yeah.
The look at,
you look at the,
the,
the Koran and you look at all the
various things that people fight for and
people that believe,
you know,
just our doctrine.
Like,
you know,
the,
the way women are supposed to be treated,
the way gays are supposed to be treated,
that all those things.
I mean,
you're,
you're talking about some shit that's
been around for thousands of years and
it's,
it's so hard to move past that stuff.
It's so hard when,
when that's ingrained in a culture and
people are fighting for it and willing to
die for it as is,
it's so difficult to re restructure that.
Oh,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
And yet we still,
you know,
we continue to try,
it's,
it's interesting when you look
at history like of Afghanistan,
so,
but we only try when
there's resources there.
Oh.
So it's really fucked up.
I mean we're,
we really only,
we really only get concerned about
people's wellbeing when we can make some
money out of this
situation there.
There's gotta be,
yeah,
exactly.
There's gotta be some kind
of political agenda involved,
which is,
you know,
it's one of the more
frustrating as you see.
Yeah.
One more.
One of the more frustrating things you
see in American politics where I just rip
my hair out.
If we found a fucking gigantic
plot of oil under North Korea,
thanks for give very juicy.
Very quickly.
If we found out like tomorrow that this
fucking hundred trillion dollars with an
oil in north,
this is a very particularly unusually
rich mine of oil and be like,
Oh shit,
we did cut off their fucking Internet.
We'd cut off their electricity.
I mean shit would get crazy really
quickly if they found out that all the
worlds,
you know,
resource supplies,
as far as like natural gas,
oil,
whatever the fuck we need was,
it was in North Korea.
We could,
the whole world could live fine.
We'd be there.
Well,
you know,
and one of the other things though too
is that we get the double edge sword
where if we don't go,
we're criticized when we go,
we're criticized.
So I mean we're,
you know,
it's,
there,
there's always a lot more detailed and
we're not privy to all the Intel reports.
You know,
when people,
like when the Syrian rebellion
started and people asked,
you know,
hey,
should we go into Syria?
Should we supply them with weapons?
What should we do?
You know,
we're basing our assumptions
off what the media tells us,
which there's so much bullshit
wrapped up in that as well.
We're not privy to all the Intel that
people in the Pentagon or getting.
Um,
so it's really hard for us to
speculate on what we should do.
But in the end,
we ended up arming a
whole lot of people and,
uh,
at least a decent sized portion of
those people ended up being isis,
you know,
which it's,
it's a,
it's,
it's crazy at the level,
you know,
where's the accountability in that?
Well,
it's almost like the,
you know what you're
saying is like that the,
the average person is not privy to the
information that the Pentagon is getting,
but the Pentagon is not,
they're not.
They're like,
don't you really have to be there to get
like hands on information and who the
fuck can do that other than the people
that are directly interacting with them
and they're not dictating
policy and what are they doing?
Well,
but they're there.
They're feeding information,
feeding information,
they're following orders,
they're fighting battles.
And you know,
ultimately you got two people
that are against each other.
They don't speak the
same fucking language.
You're,
you're in a country that,
you know,
ideally we shouldn't be in
the first place and you know,
people are trying to kill everybody.
The whole thing is fucking crazy and t
to be able to try to make sense out of
that.
The only thing that gives me any hope
whatsoever is the idea that over time,
logic and reason and
education will work out.
And as long as we're on
the right side of all that,
that with all the blunders
and the mistakes and all the,
the,
the friendly fire and all the civilian
casualties that are unfortunate that over
time,
logic and reason will
settle all these issues.
But that doesn't say Shit Shit like
that happening today in France.
It doesn't seem like that's the case.
It seems like we're going to go birth
to grave and live in this fucking crazy
world of bombs and bullets and,
and then we're going to,
we're going to end and the,
the,
our generation,
the next generation is going to have
to fucking pick up and carry the ball.
Yeah.
And it's going to fuel the argument of,
Hey,
look,
you know,
and,
and of course me having gone to Iraq,
I would,
you know,
I,
I would love to believe that whether
we should have been there or not,
at least going kept the
violence there on us.
Who signed up for it.
Feiss you know,
here on,
on,
on our land,
etc. You know,
you
like to hope that's true because you,
you've had so many friends
that you've lost doing it.
But,
uh,
you know,
when you see things like
what happened in Paris,
that's going to feel the argument of,
well,
you know,
we have to be in these
countries to control these
things because they hate us so
much that they're willing
to go to extremes that,
that we're not,
you know,
Isis,
Taliban,
al Qaeda,
they're never going to stop
hating Western civilization.
They're never going to stop attacking us.
Um,
you know,
uh,
Palestine,
Israel never going to
stop going back and forth,
which is one of the reasons they hate
us anyways because of our support of
Israel as well.
It is such a complex scenario that,
I mean,
you,
you could discuss it with
scholars for hours and hours,
um,
and you wonder when we're going to find
a better way to solve these problems.
Yeah.
If,
if ever,
and you know,
every time something looks cool like
him Momar Kadafi getting killed me watch
that crazy footage of those
guys sticking knives up as,
you know,
killing them.
And you're like,
well,
they got rid of that asshole.
Libby has way more fucked up now.
Who's running it?
We spent,
you know,
that's,
that's one,
uh,
one of my,
I mean,
we spend a lot of money,
a lot of money on some,
you know,
and on some really stupid stuff too.
I don't know if he,
if he had a chance to take a look at,
um,
uh,
what rand Paul was posting.
He was airing some grievances and
he was talking about millions.
We expend to like,
you know,
monitor monkeys throwing,
I don't know,
throwing feces.
I mean,
we're weird things that we actually
legitimately did spend money on,
which is just out of this world.
But we spent a lot of money on what
we did in Libya and we have no,
does this administration,
do they have any idea
who's in control of that?
We did something similar in Egypt too.
I mean,
it's just the,
the,
the accountability and the dollar spent,
you know,
it's very frustrating.
Yeah.
And incredibly frustrating.
And it's also,
it's hard for people that are in
America who live this life of privilege.
And this easy first world
civilization that we have.
It's hard for us to even understand that
there's these things going on in these
other countries.
We see it on television,
we read about it in the news,
but to actually witness it,
it's,
it's so difficult for us to,
to even comprehend war you.
You've been there,
you,
you've taken part in
and you've been there,
you've been boots on the ground,
you've experienced it,
you've lost friends.
Your perspective,
it must be so difficult to communicate
with someone who has this idealistic
point of view where they've,
they're completely insulated from the
reality of what a war actually is.
It's,
it's very hard.
It's very hard.
And at the same time,
you have to fight against your own,
your own bias because
when you do go to war,
um,
of course you want to believe that you
were there for all the right reasons.
You know,
you don't want to believe
in conspiracy theories,
et cetera.
Um,
and it's,
it's hard to do.
It's hard to read all the,
you know,
hey,
now we're seeing lessons learned,
you know,
was the Iraq war complete waste?
And you know,
when you,
when you saw as we've withdrawed in,
in what's place in
Iraq to,
to people like me and
in all my friends and,
and,
and you know,
my generation of military
that have gone over there.
And that's heartbreaking to see it begin
to collapse and violence spiked to the
levels that have,
that have started since
isis has been born.
And again,
the argument,
well,
if we never went over in the first
place in Isis would never been born,
but have we never left prematurely,
they probably wouldn't
have been born either.
There's so many ways you can go with
it and everybody wants to be right.
You know,
I don't think anybody truly has all the
information to say exactly what would
have been the right decision,
but it's all just really,
really sad.
And,
and we,
we elect people to make
these decisions for us.
And you know,
I,
I can't say that I feel comfortable
with all those people in there.
You know,
I feel like the private sector is
much more accountable today than the
government sector.
I mean,
it's easy to get fire
in the private sector.
You either deliver towards
the bottom line or you don't,
and you go away in the public sector,
you can do all kinds of stuff
and still get reelected.
Yeah.
I mean,
Marion Barry came back as the mayor of
Washington DC after he got caught smoking
crack,
he came back and won.
That's an extreme example obviously,
but the,
the shit that goes on behind the
scenes that we don't know about,
and then you compare it
to what we do know about,
you've got a guy like Dick Cheney,
who was the CEO of Halliburton accompany,
that's they make their money off
of rebuilding shit that he blew up.
And then he gets into office and
he's the fucking vice president.
And also we're blowing
shit up and Halliburton is
getting these huge fucking no
bid contracts.
There's no,
no one competing against them.
And they're making billions
of dollars rebuilding.
And if you talk to the people that
are involved in the rebuilding,
they're like,
look,
we're just putting fucking water treatment
plants and factories in place that we
don't even,
they don't even need,
they're not even gonna use,
but we have the contracts to do them.
So we're building this
so we could submit it and we can get paid.
So we get smitten invoice.
Yet it's,
it's,
it's sad and look,
you know,
people love to point at
America at our corruption,
but you know,
we talked about him.
I mean,
there's corruption at every single level.
Me,
every single click,
you know,
when you put money and power on the
line does something to a human being,
especially power.
I mean,
that's my argument when all this police
brutality shit's going on in everybody's
like,
hey,
you know,
the police need to be accountable.
Yes,
they've,
they absolutely do.
Here's part of the problem.
I don't think anybody is
fucking qualified to be a cop.
I think when you're a cop for 2030 years,
you're dodging bullets and every fucking
door you opened up every domestic
dispute.
Some chick might stab you in the neck
for arresting her husband that beat the
shit out of her.
I mean,
people are fucking crazy.
You're dealing with worst case
scenario almost every day.
And I think we,
we want cops to be better at their job.
We don't want cops to kill people,
but I really don't know how many people
are qualified for that fucking job.
I don't know how many people can do it.
And it's not like we
get the same caliber person that goes
on to be a doctor that ends up being and
going to be a police officer.
It's a very different,
it's like you said,
it's a very difficult job,
but they're human and we are,
we are flawed.
I mean we are,
we are all completely flawed and it's uh,
yeah,
I mean that,
that's,
that's been a frustrating thing,
you know,
in this country where we see this
argument and in that goes back to what I
talked about before.
Depending on what news station you go on,
you get one side completely over here.
Then you get the other side completely
over there and nobody willing to really
discuss this middle area cause both
sides make really good points in certain
areas,
but nobody wants to discuss the weight.
Hey guys,
there is a possibility that both of
you guys are right in certain areas and
maybe if we can come to terms on this,
we could actually fix the problem.
I really felt that with Ferguson,
with Ferguson,
I felt like God damn everybody's
digging their line in the sand.
And there's people on one side that think
that the j the killing was unjustified
and that the cop should have
been tried and should go to jail.
But they're unwilling to look at the
fact that that guy robbed a fucking
convenience store moments
before he was shot.
That guy definitely tried
to get the gun from the cop.
I mean he had,
uh,
he,
he was shot in his fucking
hand that he was trying,
it was a close range in this
cop's car and they're like,
look at its face.
The cop was barely hit.
Now you know as well as,
I know you could go through a fucking
five round fight and look like you were
not barely hit.
Meanwhile,
you're getting rocked like sometimes
swelling takes hours to show up.
Sometimes people don't do,
they don't swell.
Sometimes you get caught
clean and there's no mark on.
You get knocked out
cold and you look fine.
Like this idea that he should have a
fucking hatchet wound in his forehead
before he,
he's pulling the trigger on this kid.
Then you look at the other side that says,
well,
these are terrible people and the,
you know,
he should have been shot
because he was a bad person.
Okay,
what would you be like if you
grew up in that and absolutely.
What would you be like if you were
that kid and that fucking impoverished
neighborhood with no hope?
Everyone around you is doing drugs.
Everyone around you is involved in crime.
That's the real fucking problem.
The real problem is you're wasting the
potential of this young human being
because he's being forced to develop
in this horrible situation that nobody
seems to have any incentive
to go in and try to fix.
Nobody is talking about going into these
neighborhoods and trying to clean them
up and using massive federal resources
and money to try to try to calm these
fucking places down and try to
give these people some hope.
Then there's both sides.
Oh,
absolutely.
Digging their heels in the sand.
Right.
And we
asked these police officers
to do an awfully tough job.
You know,
they,
they don't,
they're not going to get credit for all
the everyday right things they're going
to do,
but when,
when it hits the fan and they got
to make the really tough decision,
we scrutinize the living hell out of Oh,
for sure.
And it becomes very difficult,
but I couldn't agree more.
Um,
you know,
there's,
Gosh,
I,
I to say that I hate
both political parties equally.
Um,
you know,
just because of the,
the,
the lack of integrity.
I tend in a lot of areas to lean
more towards the conservative side,
but then there's some areas where,
you know,
I've got completely liberal views as well.
Um,
but on this one,
you know,
when you really look,
and I've had these,
these great conversations with,
with kids who did grow up
in neighborhoods like this,
and you try and have these discussions
and you look at it and you look at it,
the one thing that you can look at to say,
you know,
at least one thing that
can be the equalizers.
Education.
You know where I live in,
I live in a suburb,
north Atlanta and in the school districts
by where I live are the best in the
state.
Now,
if I had to send my kids
to a South Fulton County,
which is in south Atlanta to
one of those public schools,
there's no way in hell
it's on my daughter's here.
No Way.
Both public schools,
both funded by taxes,
but the difference is completely different
than the one fucked one is a platinum
level school.
And the other one isn't.
I mean,
d minus level school.
And so these kids don't have a choice
to which parents they're born or which
household they're born into.
Our forced,
if they,
if they already have parents that were
caught in a poverty cycle that don't have
a whole lot of education and
perspectives to their home,
life isn't great,
then they go to a school
that's not so great and,
and then you've got the,
the criminal justice system that
can continually just recycles.
And we,
we,
we put them in jail,
ain't,
I mean it's,
it's a situation where the
odds are not in their favor.
And if there's one,
you know,
if there's two things that in this
country that we should have with all the
money we have and that we send overseas,
I mean one of them should
definitely be platinum schools are,
our schools should be phenomenal.
You know,
you've got this tenure thing,
which makes it really hard
to fire a bad teacher.
You know,
the whole system needs to be reformed
badly because education could be that
great equalizer regardless
of what ethnicity you are.
And when you find out how
much teachers get paid.
I mean,
I know UFC fighters complain about pay.
Find out how much a
fucking teacher gets paid.
Jesus Christ,
they're making a teacher
salary in one night.
It's,
but I mean,
obviously you can't compare the two,
but you,
you,
you have to look at the,
just the sheer ridiculousness of teacher
salaries and the idea that this is,
these are the people that are supposed
to literally teach our children the
skills they need to get
through life successfully.
And we're,
we're giving them no incentive.
We're,
we're asking them to do it almost
against their best interest financially.
We're almost like,
look,
I know you're smart.
I know you have all this education.
I know he could probably make a lot of
money going and working for some company
that's very profitable.
But you know,
you want to be a teacher,
guess what?
You're going to make 35
grand a year and you know,
you're gonna,
you're gonna have months off and you know,
while you're in school,
you know,
you're going to fucking deal with
the dregs of society's children.
People that you know have all sorts of
criminal pasts and all sorts of drug
problems and violence.
These kids are gonna grow up with
violence and you're going to be forced to
corral them and try to
wrangle them in class.
I mean I've seen videos of of teachers
getting assaulted in classes where you
know,
uh,
there was some video or some
girl jumped up of receipt,
started beating the shit out of this
teacher and then he just started fighting
back and then other kids jumped a
teacher and it just fucking chaos.
Imagine you're doing this for 35 grand
a year or whatever the fuck they're
getting paid.
My,
my older sister,
she was a teacher for years.
She left because that reason she
wasn't getting paid very much.
And then anytime that she
had a problem with a student,
if the parent got involved,
the administration would normally take
the side of the parent and the student
and she wasn't allowed to,
to actually teach and discipline a child
who is putting up their own barriers to
their education.
It became very frustrating for
you and you're dealing with,
you know,
you deal with a kid,
get a kid that's 16 years old,
16 years of conditioning,
of life,
of experiences and all the stuff
that they're getting from their home.
I mean,
you can only guess,
you can only guess as to what,
what their background is like it's her.
It's really horrific and a
lot of ways that we have.
The one thing that is just so important
is human beings like the developing
human beings.
Maybe if you want it,
I've always said this,
if you want to have a
culture with less losers,
like wouldn't that be like the
best way to keep America strong,
develop less losers?
Well,
where do you develop less losers?
You fucking go with children.
You try to figure out what's the
best way to develop children.
And it's one of the least the areas where
we put the least amount of resources
in this country.
And when you look at,
I mean,
what is it less than 50%
of people pay their taxes?
Is that true at the,
it's somewhere around that.
Look up that stat.
If he can,
but I mean there there's a big percentage
of people that don't pay their taxes
and so you get a lot
of people to complain.
You know,
guys like I don't even want
to know what you pay in taxes.
I know I pay a lot in taxes and it sucks
every time you get to write that check,
you're paying a ton in taxes.
But imagine what it's like if
you got a lot of people that,
that vice living off the government are
now providing for themselves and paying
taxes and you know,
it's what you said,
you know,
having a country with
less losers and it really,
the key is education.
Yeah.
I don't get the,
I know there's a lot of people that have
a gigantic issue when you look it up,
a lot of people have a
gigantic issue with taxes.
And uh,
my,
my issue is waste and fraud.
My issue is bureaucracy.
My issue is the amount of people that
have jobs and only exist because the,
the,
the government is trying to create jobs
for these people because this is sort of
some way to feed into the economy.
And this is,
this is a bunch of
unnecessary fucking jobs.
There's a bunch of laws that shouldn't
exist as a bunch of people reinforcing
those ridiculous jobs and the reinforcing
those ridiculous laws and that becomes
a job.
It becomes an industry.
I mean,
the war on drugs is a
perfect example of that.
And I think that if we could figure out
a way to utilize taxes in some sort of
an efficient and equitable
way,
I'm all for paying taxes.
I mean,
I pay him anyway.
You're not going to not do it.
You're not going to jail.
I'm not Wesley Snipes in it.
And just trying to avoid
taxes and they leave,
walked up Lauren Hill from the fucking
food Fujis like she's some sort of a
threat to the,
the general piece of our culture.
And it's,
you know,
and it's,
it's 26% is that what it says?
46% of American households
won't pay federal income
taxes in 2008 that was 2011.
It's probably even higher now still.
Yeah,
it's still pretty high.
But it,
you know,
it's interesting you say that because,
um,
you know,
when,
when you look at,
at lockup,
so there's 50 new crime
laws on average made a year,
which is about a total of 4,500 laws,
which is 2,700 pages of criminal laws.
And then over 50% of the jail population
are over drugs for nonviolent crimes.
God,
you know,
we've got,
in America,
we've got 5% of the world's population,
25% though of the world's prisoners
are in American and incredible.
And in 53% of the people that go to
jail or beneath the poverty line,
53% are below the poverty line as if you
expect people that are just scratching
by to follow the rules.
But I mean,
how do you fix that?
I mean,
if you look at what,
you know,
when you look at Brazil for instance,
where the,
the,
we think that there's a gap between
the haves and have nots in America.
It's enormous in Brazil.
It is enormous.
And it's funny because
when you human beings,
we have ingenuity.
I mean it's like you talk about
we have a drive for discovery,
we will find a way.
And when you,
when you have that poverty
trap in certain areas,
they're going to find a way in,
in,
in Brazil and some of those novellas,
they found a black market
illegal way of sustaining life.
And,
and,
and it's very difficult there.
I mean,
were these favelas in the hills?
I mean those police don't have a
whole lot of control over those.
Yeah.
If any at all.
The favelas is a very fascinating
situation where you've got this group of
people above the people that have money
and the people that are in these places
with this incredible view are
the people that are really poor.
I mean,
it's the opposite of
how it is in California.
The Hollywood hills where all the rich
folks live and down on the bottoms were
the,
the regular folks live.
The people that can afford
to live in the hills,
they get that incredible view that
people that are down on the ground,
those are the people that a man,
I'd love to live up in
those hills and the hills.
It's really kind of crazy.
Just wedged in,
I mean,
stacked boxes on top of one another with,
with just a horrible standard of living.
But uh,
yeah,
it makes it really difficult when you
look at our criminal justice system and
in,
in some of those things you talked about.
But one of the things that,
that I look at too is where you
get these career politicians that,
you know,
yeah,
they've got experienced
balancing a budget,
but they've got a staff
that kind of looks at it.
You know,
my experience coming from the military,
then over to the private sector in
seeing the accountability there.
You know,
if a CFO of a publicly traded company,
you are scrutinized to the
t on every expenditure,
what that's gonna do to your stock price.
These are men and women that are very,
very capable of going into Washington DC
in leaning out some of the problems we
have there.
They're very capable of doing that,
but of course they don't
want to give up all their,
their freedoms.
They don't want to get paid 170 k year
because they're making a heck of a lot
more than that with this,
this publicly traded company too,
but to go be a politician of every
little bit of their life scrutinize like,
hey,
this lady back in high school did this.
That deters a lot of these
really brilliant people
in the private sector from
going and running for
office where you don't,
they may be a lot more capable than his
career long politician who got an office
when they were 32 years old and
has been in public office since.
Yeah.
Isn't it kind of a crazy
situation we find ourselves in,
especially today with social media and
the Internet and the accountability that
these people have about their private
lives is the only people that were going
to get to run for office are people
that no one can fucking relate to cause
they've never taken any chances.
They never done anything fucked up.
They never had a fucking
orgy that never done coke.
They've never done anything stupid.
They never,
you know,
they did just everything that they've
done that was crazy or fun would
automatically disqualify them for the job.
But we can't take into the,
we can't in our minds rationalize the
idea that people make mistakes and through
those mistakes you build
character and you become a better,
I'll tell you,
you know,
I run a company and you know,
the people that we bring into the company
and the company helps veterans get
jobs and get out.
One of my prerequisites is I don't
want perfect people on staff.
Not that we're,
we don't discriminate
against them by any means,
but I like bringing people on my team,
specifically my leadership team,
who have been down and out before,
who have had to dig themselves back
up and overcome adversity because when
things go bad,
they don't panic.
You know how they're gonna respond already
because they've been through things
in their life before where
it's been very difficult.
It's one of the values that we pitched
to companies on hiring more veterans is,
look,
you're going to hire these folks
when there's a bad day at work.
Sales are down or somebody
didn't show up for work.
They're not going to panic about it.
That,
that,
that's,
that's small to them.
This is minor.
Um,
that's a very good point.
It's,
you know,
those are the people
that I want on my team.
Same thing in political office.
I mean,
you get all these perfect people,
then you throw them into DC where
then they start having orgies.
That's when they start
going a little crazy.
And you know,
they have a contained for so long and
you get the Anthony Wiener's up there.
Well this fucking shit
that's going on with Clinton.
You know,
this,
this thing that this guy who,
uh,
had an island and essentially
had these underage sex slaves.
Do you know about this whole thing?
Oh,
I went and visited this island.
fucking Christ.
Google that.
Jamie.
Yes.
I got an a ton of heat and social
media because I said yesterday,
you know,
the John Jones
thing comes out in,
I don't want to get to perform off 70.
But I said,
you know,
they asked,
will he ever be able to overcome this?
I said,
look in a country where Bill Clinton can
do what he did and then become more the
highest paid public speakers in
the hero of his political party.
Yes.
Jon Jones can be forgiven for,
for snorting cocaine.
Yeah.
He said a 27 year old people went nuts
and on social media it was all stand can
pears,
Jon Jones to Bill Clinton.
Well you did.
But it's correct.
It's a good comparison.
It's the scenario.
We'll look at this man,
this,
this is really fucking crazy.
This.
Um,
especially if Hillary is
running for president right now,
which apparently it looks like it's
going to be Hillary versus Jeb Bush.
This guy,
Jeffrey Epstein,
was accused of luring
underage girls to his,
he had some,
some,
some retreat somewhere and
Clinton went there several times.
So it's just fucked me.
I mean,
he's a fucking wild man.
Bill Clinton was a god damn wild man.
We know that for a fact.
I,
you know,
I don't want to divulge his name,
but I spent time with a
guy who's worth $2 billion.
He's,
he's one of the most
successful CEOs in the country.
And,
and he told me a story where he hung out
with Bill Clinton one time when he was
president and,
and you know,
they're at some there at some
establishment and bill says,
Hey,
we should buy those
girls down there shots.
And the guy,
the gentleman I know goes,
Mr President,
I don't think that's a good idea.
If you want to do that,
let me order them and send them down.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I'm going to go ahead and do it.
And he said that his personal security,
his secret service members used to
call Bill Clinton's to call him Elvis.
That was their code
name for him with Elvis.
Wow.
Who's a wild motherfucker.
Look,
he had that sickness.
He had it.
He had a full blown people to,
I mean his Iq is
supposedly off the charts.
He's one of the brightest guys.
That's why he likes pussy so much.
He knows Mike Tyson said it best.
He said,
if God may found better than puts,
he kept it to himself.
You know,
I've got a phrase that I
use to all married men.
Um,
you know,
I tell him all the time,
I said,
listen,
you know,
and I tell to a lot of fighters when
they're married as well because they
travel,
there's gonna be a lot of temptation.
I said,
look,
pussy is undefeated.
It's never like,
it's never lost.
If you go head to head with it,
you are going to lose.
And you need to avoid those situations.
You need to avoid those situations.
And,
and you know,
I've got certain protocols
if I go out to call a fight,
you know,
and in a,
if,
if I'm,
if I'm going to go out and
it's Vegas like last weekend,
you know,
I'm not going to go out and have
more than two drinks out in public,
in an environment where
I am not with my wife.
And then once its second drink is up,
I'm going back to her.
I'm not even gonna,
I'm not gonna put myself
in that situation.
You know,
when you've got a Ferrari at home,
you don't go out test driving
Cadillacs and you know what I mean?
And so kind of like brings
a good car these days.
CTSV you ever drive one
Goddamn hell of an automobile?
Probably more reliable there.
You're ruining your room.
I know what you're saying.
I'm just standing up with Cadillacs.
I'm a car guy.
Sorry.
Canada land,
Cat Ferrari's,
a fucking breakdown on the highway.
That's there.
But either way,
don't take it on.
Don't take it on head to head.
Don't go head to head with it.
You will lose.
It's never lost.
Yes.
I like what you're saying up to that
point up to the Cadillac Ferrari thing,
but no.
Yeah.
I mean,
look,
we're,
you're fighting fucking
thousands of years of DNA.
Essentially.
You're fighting all the DNA that existed,
that kept human beings alive when 50%
of the babies would die when most people
never live to be past 30 I mean,
you're fighting that.
I mean the urge that men have to,
to,
to procreate,
that is,
that's the reason why there's people,
we were lazy about procreating,
about having sex if it's
having sex was as all right.
Nobody would have fucking kids.
No,
none of them have children
and I have children.
You would never know what a great
experience it is to be a father,
how fantastic it is,
how enriching it is.
If you just looked at it from watching
some guy and his wife with the kids
crying at the movie theater or
someone at the airport like,
fuck that.
I'm young.
I'm single.
I like,
I like waking up when I want without
someone yelling at me without some fucking
kid that I have to clean their diaper.
But then you have kids
you understand like,
oh,
this isn't somebody else's kid.
This is my kid,
this is a part of me.
This is love.
That's indescribable.
And then it becomes this sort of new level
of your life that it's very difficult
to explain to someone who
doesn't have children.
Yeah,
I have a lot of single friends.
I have a lot of comics that
are my friends that you know,
that don't have kids.
And they go,
I'll fucking willy nilly crazy
slinging dick all over the world.
They're fucking wild men.
And I tried it.
They're like,
man,
I,
you know,
I would hate to have kids.
I'm like,
yeah,
you say that.
I have no idea.
It's the meat.
To me,
it's the meaning of life.
I couldn't imagine,
you know,
I had my first daughter and it wasn't
that long after I'd gotten back from Iraq
the second time.
And it was such a powerful,
one of the most powerful
experience in my life.
You go from an environment where
you see so much life taken.
And then I'm sitting in
a roommate and I see,
you know,
life given.
And you know,
for me at that time I was already thinking
about getting out of the military and
there's a lot of guilt inside me
for doing that because I was so,
I was so good at being a marine officer.
I loved leading marines.
You know,
I didn't love going to what
I loved leading marines
and you feel guilty because
you know,
these guys are going to keep
going back and what you should do.
Um,
but when my first daughter was born,
it was just an absolutely
life changing experience.
I mean,
for me,
the rest of this is a puppet show.
I mean you,
you,
we do all these things that we can
get home to where we want to be.
I can get on my,
my living room floor and just be with my
three daughters and they bring out the
best side of me.
They inspire me.
They're by far my best accomplishment.
I mean,
I absolutely live for them and you know,
you,
you can relate.
You know,
when you sit down and you
lay next to a girl that,
that you may have just had,
you know,
a random relations with,
that's nothing like laying down next
to your child is a fall asleep and they
lean over and just tell you,
I love you.
Daddy
is very different.
But if the chicks really hot,
it's still awesome.
I'm just saying if you're not
married and the chicks really high,
it's pretty God damn good,
especially whatever.
But yeah,
there's just a different level.
Like,
you know,
I visited my daughter at school today
and she didn't know we're going to be
there.
Um,
and uh,
she turns around and sees me,
you know,
she's six and her eyes light up and
she runs over and gives me a hug.
And this is a warm that comes over you
that no one will ever understand unless
you have a kid.
He just won't,
you know,
and I'm not saying that it's a better
life and I'm not saying that I'm a better
person.
I'm not saying that everybody has to go
out and have a kid cause I hate those
arguments.
And I used to hate those
arguments when I was single.
People would say,
look good.
You know what?
Fucking,
you're not mature until you have a kid.
You know?
I believe there's a lot of people
that don't need to have kids.
I believe there's a lot of people that
they can contribute to this society,
to this culture,
to this world without ever procreate.
Absolutely.
There's nothing wrong with that.
For me though,
I'm such a selfish person.
Um,
so I shouldn't even say self.
I'm so self obsessed with my,
my own goals and my,
I'm always in my head.
I'm always concentrating on
my thoughts and my emotions.
That having a child made me rewire
it rewired all of my thinking because
everything I do now,
I think about my children.
I think about them as little human beings
and I'm responsible for little human
beings that I,
and I can't do anything too crazy.
I can't do anything that's
going to risk my life.
I'm,
I have to take care of them.
I mean,
it's just,
there's a thing about that I never
used to think or worry about.
I mean,
I certainly didn't want to die before,
but I never used to think about it the
way I think about it now because now I
think about leaving behind my
children and that's a horrific idea.
Powerful.
You know,
you,
you couldn't say it any better.
I mean it was at the time
I had my first daughter,
I had zero fears.
I mean,
I took a lot of risks,
um,
in,
in my job at that time and did not care.
Then all of a sudden you have this child
and this fear is introduced to your
world.
Not just about you dying,
lean behind,
but what about the child?
You know,
they're going to drive one day,
they're going to get their heartbroken
when day or what happens here.
He and I had a,
I had a friend of mine who
lives right up the block and he,
his firstborn son,
11 years old or on a ski trip in Colorado
and someone was towing a paraplegic
down the slope.
And the,
the wire they were using to tow him,
hit his son in the neck
and killed him instantly.
Oh God.
I mean it was,
and it to today to be there for him.
And not that I was able to do much,
but to,
to see him have to recover from that is,
you know,
look,
I've been on the battlefield and,
and I've seen a lot of,
a lot of things I would
never wish on anybody.
Um,
but losing your own child is just brutal.
It's brutal.
It must be indescribable.
What did you know Jeremy Stevens brought
this up when he was on a podcast about
fighters having daughters?
All daughters.
You've got all daughters.
Jon Jones has all daughters.
Mark Coleman has r.
Dot.
All daughters.
I mean this is like a long list.
Alpha males of these savages that only
have daughters is that the universe is
trying to balance itself out.
You know,
what is that?
There's something with it with,
you know,
your natural testosterone count is so hot.
I don't know.
There's,
I've,
I've read different articles about it.
I remember before I had my third,
Chris Weidman was trying
to give me some tips,
like,
you got to eat this.
They got to do it.
Just like that.
I mean,
he,
he gave me the play by play and
he says that's how he had his boy.
You know,
he,
that,
that's exactly how he did it.
And he followed the steps scenario.
Of course,
I wasn't patient enough to put
in the amount of time he did.
And I don't believe it.
Dumb luck.
I think it's,
you know,
the fucking Zigzag,
the,
the right fucking sperm
gets to the right egg.
But Bam,
Jetson millionaire,
I don't think there's any
logic or science to it.
It's a bunch of old wives' tales.
Yeah.
I mean,
I go home and I am surrounded
by estrogen meets around it.
It's an incredible,
it's a weakness.
It's,
you gotta get,
they get you.
Oh yeah.
I got a bit I'm doing about
it in my act right now.
It's just cause it's so like when you're
around a bunch of people who think
completely different than you,
you really understand like the,
the,
the troubles that men
and women have tried.
You know,
this,
this thing where we're trying to
figure out how to get along together.
You,
you,
you really understand it at a base level.
Yeah.
Oh this is like,
this is like a totally different animal.
This is like a kangaroo trying to live
within Orangutang like you guys are
fucking w there's so different.
It's so different.
And then you have these weird traders
that sort of like cross the barrier and
try to meet in the middle
and like mineral assholes.
I'm different and they try to like
sell themselves internetive to men.
But meanwhile they are men and then your
wives are using it as an example in an
argument with you that that got some
fucking creep and then they always get
caught doing something fucking gross
and those get caught raping somebody or
something like,
ah,
yeah,
there you go.
Yeah.
Like Bill Cosby,
perfect example.
Bill Cosby forever was telling
Comedians don't tell dirty jokes.
She never tell dirty jokes.
Crushing Eddie Murphy for he was,
oh and not just Eddie Murphy.
He did it to v Chris Rock.
He did it to a host of
especially black comedians.
Meanwhile,
if the stories are true
with 30 women aren't buyers,
it's getting a little ridiculous,
but that's,
it's exactly what you find out.
I mean Ted Haggard,
that fucking that preacher who was a
always like a railing against gay people
and against,
you know,
God says that gay men
should not be married.
It's an abomination.
Me By always doing math and
fucking getting gay hookers.
It's all the same shit.
It's like these,
these fucking traitors that cross this,
this,
this line where they're trying to portray
themselves as the alternative to tea
to reality.
They believe they're the enlightened one.
Fucking gross scams,
disgusting male feminists.
That's what we're talking about.
You'll hear me out there.
You creeps.
You need to do dead lifts all of you.
It is funny because there's been a
couple times where I've started to get
pretty,
pretty serious on the podcast here.
And then Joel complete,
like when I talked about
the Friday and the county,
he completely turned
important or you know,
hey,
uh,
you know,
he,
he's laying next to my
daughter instead of like,
you know,
another woman,
he throws that one in there.
It reminds me,
I did the Howard stern show once,
and this is back in 2000 I was an
active duty Marine Corps captain.
Was that when you were in the WC?
We do light heavyweight champion.
Yeah.
And so the versus network,
God rest their souls,
rest in peace.
They somehow get me on the
Howard stern show and I go,
well,
what am I going on for it?
I'm worried it's an active duty captain.
The Marine Corps.
I can get in a lot of trouble
for saying the wrong thing here.
And so they tell me,
oh,
don't worry,
you're just there to present
a check from the WEC.
But if he will start asking you questions,
try to stay on as long as you can.
Okay,
cool.
What's the contest?
The hottest chick with the ugliest car.
Oh God.
I mean hip,
the ugliest scar.
And so a fuck.
But it,
you know,
at one point there's actually still,
yeah,
I think the video is still somewhere,
but,
uh,
we're doing this interview and,
and Howard was being very serious and he
was asking me what it's like for these
young men and women that
deploy and how difficult it is.
And I'm getting into it and,
and I could see his wheels turning,
like he's getting sympathetic and every,
and there's really serious,
and this isn't his brand.
So he thinks on his feet and he's nimble
and right out of nowhere he comes.
Wow,
that is so mean.
How old are you?
25 years.
The pressure,
you guys,
you must be jerking off what,
seven,
eight times a day?
What are you doing?
And
I mean,
I,
I knew I was worn,
you know,
hey,
look,
this guy's gonna throw
a curve ball or to a,
you know,
I wasn't ready for that.
I forget how I tiptoed
and tap danced around it.
But I mean,
it was,
uh,
it wasn't easy.
It wasn't easy.
Yeah,
there's no,
there's no easy way to tiptoe around that.
No,
no.
And you know,
there's marines out there
just waiting in the hall.
Hey,
junior,
that damn cat than on there talking about
jerking off on the Howard stern show.
Yes.
No weird.
You can admit to jerking off.
It's a very strange thing.
It's was like,
I don't understand that world.
I'll never understand a world
where someone gets angry
at you for talking about
jerking off.
Well,
it's like women in shitting.
Yeah.
It doesn't happen.
Some chicks will get down.
They'll tell you.
They'll let you know.
I appreciate that.
You know,
when a guy who can't,
you know,
I had a friend,
he uh,
he was over this girl's house.
They're about to get busy.
He went to use the bathroom.
She had forgot to flush and there was a
floater in there and he said he killed
his boner.
And he said,
he left.
And I go,
what?
She Hadi goes,
she was really hot.
I go,
you're a fucking pussy.
you'll flush it.
You man up your race,
your memory,
shake it up a little bit yourself.
The fucking Volkan neck pinch,
you know,
there's no way he was an Alpha male.
He had to be a bravo.
I don't know what he was,
you know,
I mean,
you
know him.
He's a good guy.
He'll definitely a boys.
Yeah,
maybe.
I Dunno,
I just don't understand that.
I just think,
you know,
there's a reality to this world.
Food comes in,
shit comes out,
deal with it.
It's pretty soon.
You know,
if you can't,
you know you're going to miss out on some
opportunities if you can't close those
doors of perception.
It's amazing how funny
that stuff has to kids,
by the way too.
I mean it's,
you say poop in my house and then you'd
swear you'd say it was your level of
comedian.
Dude,
my kids love to say poop.
My kids will,
I'll read stories and as I'm
reading the stories like the get,
you know,
there's a lot of times just like pauses
and like the story when you try to read
the story,
right?
And they're like,
can they pumped his past?
You know,
you've got a six year
old and a four year old.
I think it's fucking awesome.
Anytime you could say poop,
is that how old are your girls are?
Yeah,
that's,
I've got,
I've got seven,
five and one and a half.
They're so cute.
It makes you really
understand and appreciate,
really understand and appreciate the
differences between men and women on a,
uh,
like a base level having a baby grow
up to be a little girl and you go and,
and also see the variations
between the two of them.
You know?
And when I say like I get
angry at male feminism,
I don't mean that I'm,
I don't think that everyone should have
equal rights cause that's not what I
mean at all.
I just think there's a lot of policies
out there that are passing themselves off
as a better alternative
to a masculine man.
And that masculinity for whatever
reason is under attack is wrong.
Yeah.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's,
it's wrong for you.
The strong toxic masculinity.
I've heard this expression many times
like what are you fucking talking about?
Like there's nothing wrong with
women being feminine either.
And that's the other thing about women
being feminine is that somehow or
another,
a lot of these women who are like pro
equal rights will get upset if a girl
wants to dress sexy.
If a girl wants to wear what's
considered by our society to be sexually
attractive,
high heels,
short skirts that this is
playing into men's hands stuff.
Guess what?
Some women like it,
they liked dressing.
Absolutely.
There's nothing wrong with a guy
who wants to dress like that either.
Who gives a fuck like this live
and let live for whatever reason.
It only,
it only works for some people if it
suits their purpose or their ideology as
soon as it doesn't.
Any guy that likes to compete and an
aggressive sport must be a piece of shit.
Oh yeah,
that's not true.
I know it's not true.
I've experienced it.
I know a lot of guys that are really
nice people that also like to fight.
Absolutely and plenty of them in this,
this idea that that's
incomprehensible that the,
these,
these things are mutually exclusive.
I reject that.
I think it's,
I think it's preposterous.
And I think that idea is perpetrated by
people who are trying to present this
alternative to the norm,
that they know they can't compete as men.
And so they want to pretend
that somehow or another,
all the things that we associate with men,
muscle cars,
sports,
you know,
whatever,
having a big Dick,
all those things are terrible.
And that was what they are.
This,
this guy who cries every time he sees a
fucking a commercial in it with a puppy.
That's,
that's the better choice.
And you're in,
you're wrong for being the other way.
You know,
it's,
it's envy and insecurity can,
can,
can make any one of us,
I mean really ugly.
And then you hear it,
you know,
the green have you,
makes you ugly and everything.
But I think,
I think a lot of that is what it is,
creates that intolerance.
You know,
I mean,
people ask me all the time,
you know,
Oh,
you're,
you're white.
You were in the Marine Corp,
so all,
you must be,
you know,
flea against all this,
a homosexual stuff in the marriage.
I don't give a shit.
Don't care at all.
With his month is much hate
as I've seen in the world.
What do I care about?
Two people love each other.
I have no issues.
Why whatsoever with that whatsoever.
Yeah.
My issues with people that
have a problem with it.
I have a real issue for people that
have a problem with people who just love
each other.
I don't know what it's
like to want to love a man.
I don't,
I can't believe my wife loves me.
I can't believe any women love men.
Why would you want Dick that?
I don't get it.
It's a,
to me it's like having,
Dick is like having a magic trick.
Like I can't believe this works.
I can pull a rabbit out of my hat.
I can't believe you want to see this.
Like I don't understand it,
but the idea that somehow or another
it's evil that a man wants it,
but it's not evil that a woman,
let's fucking preposterous.
Who gives a shit.
It's ridiculous.
I don't care if men wear high heels.
I don't care if women
dress like a fucking biker.
I don't give a fuck as
long as you're nice.
I mean,
I've,
I have had friends and relations with
some of the weirdest fucking people across
the full spectrum of humanity.
And all I care about is,
are you nice?
Are you interesting to talk to?
Are you intelligent?
Can I,
can I enjoy my time with you without
feeling like your judging me or you're
being aggressive towards me or
passive aggressive towards me?
And I mean,
I've had some of the weirdest,
most,
uh,
aggressive conversations with people
that are supposedly progressive,
you know,
that decide before they even get
to talk to me that I'm the enemy,
you know,
because I got tattoos
or I lift weights or I,
you know,
compete in martial arts or I do,
whatever the fuck it is that they
decided was what put me into this enemy.
Bracka but those,
those,
the,
these,
these insecurities that we have
like the live and let live ideal is,
is,
is one of the best ways to live your life.
This is live and let live.
Don't create any enemies that
aren't really your enemy.
Yeah.
Well,
and you know,
we,
we make it harder on ourselves.
You know,
when you look at that,
I mean the live and let live means,
hey look,
be be concerned with your circle and be
tolerant of all those around and try to
understand,
right,
which we all,
we all make mistakes.
Certainly I do.
Um,
we make it harder because
then you look at all these,
these new things that we have
that really bolster insecurity.
If you look at Twitter for example,
Twitter is this universe full
of all of us that are really,
really insecure looking for
other people's approval.
You know,
how can I think of the next statement
that's going to get as many favorites,
likes,
retweets and getting
and get other people to,
to then,
you know,
be friend to me.
So I have so many and follow me.
And I mean it's,
it's everybody's trying to one up each
other and it's this environment where we
go out there looking to make,
I mean,
how many times we get sniped
for everything you said.
I mean,
I can't call a fight card without,
look,
we're talking for seven and a half hours,
seven and a half hours is
how long we're talking.
It's impossible.
I challenge you to find somebody who's
going to talk for seven and a half hours
and not piss you off.
At least one.
Not only that you're calling a live fight.
Well,
we're shit is going down on the
spot and sometimes you're incorrect.
Yeah,
there's nothing,
there's no way around it.
You're talking about two guys throwing
fucking bones at each other in a cage.
I mean,
they're swinging at each other
and you make mistakes and you,
you,
you don't see a choke.
You miss a position,
you know,
you,
you the,
it's going to happen.
But there's so many people out there
that just looking to point a finger and
that's where Goldie gets in trouble.
Goldberg fucking engages
with these people.
I had to pull them aside
after the NFL thing.
I go,
dude,
I fucking told you about this before.
You can't argue with these people.
Why are you arguing?
You don't even know them.
Yeah.
Who knows who,
who they are,
who knows what they're doing.
Some of them,
they don't even have an Avatar.
It's an egg.
Yeah.
And even if it isn't Avatar,
who the fuck,
how do you know if it's that them,
it could be anybody.
They could have taken a picture out of
a fucking magazine taking a camera photo
of that picture.
Use that as an Avatar.
You're a fat fuck.
You don't even know them.
Yeah.
I don't even know what they look like.
You have no idea.
You're arguing with fucking goats.
Well,
and the thing is too,
that people have to is,
is the people
well that will engage like he
does in a lot of instances.
They tend to be very passionate
and care a lot about what they do.
So it's easy to lure them in there.
So while you're trying to destroy them
and you're trying to break them down,
at least understanding
knowledge like that,
they really do care about their job and
the product they're putting out there.
They're trying to be good.
Um,
and obviously maybe they made some
mistakes and you were able to lure them in
into to saying things they didn't mean.
But there are guys out there,
you know,
I don't want to name any names,
but there are guys out there
that do commentary for MMA
that should not be doing
it.
And I can't listen.
There's guys that I can't listen to that
I literally have to turn the fucking
volume down and other
organizations because they,
they just drive me crazy.
They did.
I don't know what the fuck they're doing.
They don't know what
they're talking about.
And I get crazy.
So I understand it.
And if you think I'm one of those guys,
I get it.
I think you're wrong,
but I get it.
I understand.
But I,
I think this,
this ability to reach people
and to express your opinion,
it's way more valuable than it's negative.
I get a lot out of it.
I get a lot of the underground,
I get a lot of the criticism
and sometimes the right,
I mean,
I'm not all perfect.
Absolutely.
I fuck up call sometimes or I'll,
you know,
miss things or you know,
one of the things that
people need to consider,
you don't need to consider,
but when you're watching fights,
you're watching in the octagon.
When we're watching,
there's oftentimes like,
I think a punch landed,
but it really,
a guy tripped and it's because
of the guys back is to me.
And you can't tell if someone's standing
and your back's to you and someone
throws a punch and they
see the guy fall backwards.
You think the guy got
hurt and then they're,
the people that are watching at home
have the benefit of watching it from the
side and they're seeing a punch,
not land.
All that kind of stuff happens.
You,
you could watch the monitors I guess.
And sometimes I do,
but man,
I want to watch it live.
I don't watch those fucking
monitors so much better to watch live,
you know,
as a fan.
And you know,
I tried to stick to the monitors because
I remember the first card I call was in
Rio when Phil Davis Fault Yoda Machita
and Machita through a whole bunch of his
blitzes going away from me in India,
Phil Davidson,
it looked like they all landed and
I watched some of the replaced,
not all of them landed.
So it was,
it was one of those difficult things
where with the monitor I think I can,
I can see more.
Um,
but there's times when
they're close to me,
I can't help it.
I want to look through the cage because
I need to get in wrapped into that fight
and feel the crowd feel them.
Because look,
it's,
it's our job to,
to be provocative,
to break things down,
to make it entertaining and
all our true to do that.
There's also a voice in our ear,
multiple voices in our ear
telling us all kinds of wild,
hey look,
I've got the replay and was a Headbutt,
you know,
so there's,
there's things,
there's lots of things going on
during that seven hour period.
Um,
that that can also lead to
a distraction or lead to,
to a misstep.
Those,
those
voices in your ear,
a brutal when you're
in the middle of talk,
it's like a big point
you're trying to make.
And then someone's like,
well,
we got a replay on Ron.
You know,
look at your monitor,
look at the B monitor.
Like Ah,
and you,
you hear someone talking in your ear
while you're talking and you know that a
fucking million and a half people
are here plus our hearing you.
And then who knows how many fucking
people are gonna hear over the course of
time.
They're going to listen to that,
that broadcast.
I watched that Phil Davis,
Leo Machida fight the other day.
It was way closer than I thought it was.
And a,
I could see Phil winning.
I mean,
Phil did get takedowns and
did do damage on the ground.
And like you were saying
like a lot of those shots,
that mosquito is very,
very,
very close fight.
But a lot of people were calling in
one of the greatest robberies ever.
But man,
I watched it again.
I was like,
Ooh,
I don't think,
not so much.
And I don't think it's one
of the greatest robberies.
It's very fucking close.
And even the Cheadle Italia and you know,
when I talked to him before
his fight with CBD Holloway,
you know,
he's had to adapt his style though
because he had a whole bunch of really
contested decisions.
You know,
his rampage Jackson fight
his fight with Phil Davis.
He was leaving a lot of
fights where he felt like,
okay,
look,
I was in total control,
but he didn't.
He,
you know,
he made it confusing for the judges.
And when you do that,
look,
judges are human too.
We've talked all tonight about
how flawed we are as humans.
We all make mistakes.
And that happens there that absolutely
you've got to do the things he's had to
get more aggressive.
He can't just counter punch his head to
get a little bit more offensive with his
style to ensure that he's going to get
those decisions because if doesn't get
them,
he can't
be totally disappointed when he's
got a little bit of a passive style.
Yeah,
I'm glad he went down to one 85 I think
he should have been there all along,
but she does one of those guys who would
weigh in at two oh three two oh four
didn't cut any weight,
not crazy.
And he's not a huge,
he's not a huge middle weight.
I mean,
he walks,
he'll be,
you know,
one 97 196 when I fought at middle weight,
I would show up to the venue
at two oh seven on Tuesday,
make one 85 Friday,
fight back at tool seven on Saturday.
That was crazy.
And I was big then.
Now I look at these dudes now.
I mean they're almost
all like that anymore.
Well look at Weidman.
Why machine?
He's a big fucking guy to 25 to 30 he's
a big thick guy and he's strong as shit.
And that's one of the things I think
Machita realized in that fight.
Like,
wow,
I'm not a big middle weight.
No.
You know when you're fighting Weidman,
you unload everything but the kitchen
sink and then he waves the in afterwards.
I mean he unloaded on Weidman and Weidman
was still there and the fact that why,
I mean who thought round one Weidman gets
rate and Machida's face and starts out
striking first three rounds,
he out struck Machita.
Now it's not a pure kickboxing match.
The threat of the takedown certainly
opens up your arsenal more and limits
Leo's,
but it was still,
we've never seen someone go in there
and take that route towards beating
Machita.
Well,
he's very confident in his chin and his
knock out power and he also has a really
good sense of distance.
Yeah.
That's one thing that people
don't give him enough credit.
They think he's just his
face forward attacking guy.
Now he moves in and then he moves
back and he moves in and moves back.
He's throwing faints a lot and breed
long goes such a good fucking striking
coach.
Especially with wrestlers,
you know that he really
understands how to,
how to teach those guys how to,
how to fight with the constant threat
of the takedown and then attack off of
those.
Off of those opportunities.
You talk about controlling distanced
me when someone knocks you out with a
counter elbow.
Yeah.
How often?
I mean that is really hard to do to
Timon elbow on a counter strike and knock
somebody out.
I mean that's understanding
the range of your opponent,
how far they're a feel.
It's a feel that not every fighter has
and Chris definitely hasn't yet long ago.
Well it was also one of
those guys technically,
but he also,
I think he makes his fighters feel like
they're better than they should be.
Like he makes them feel like their rate
or run through that brick wall cause
he's just that tough
northeast gritty do like,
hey ray,
how do you think he's going
to do against Weidman and end?
He told me two days before the flight,
aw he's Brian,
he's going to smoke them.
This'll be ego run rate the room.
It's,
it's so funny to hear his
confidence and how tough he is.
Well,
he told me it was one of
Weidman's earlier victories.
Um,
I think,
uh,
I think after he fought Tom Lawler,
um,
he,
I was in the cage with
them and ray long goes,
he's a motherfucker.
I'm telling you his kids,
a motherfucker think he said to
me about why and when he goes,
we're all lucky he's fighting.
Trust me,
we're all lucky he's in a fucking cage
fighting because if he was out there,
if he didn't have an outlet,
oh Christ,
no shows.
I've seen some shit with
this kid and the gym.
That'd be a great land and will be
a great Reebok tee shirt for wide.
All luck.
He's fighting it that or he's a
motherfucker when you look at him too.
He's so handsome and so it looks so nice.
He's a little more respectable looking
young man to be such a fucking murderer
in there.
He did that.
He did the,
the desk show at this one time.
He's got his wife,
his kids up there.
And it's like you said,
just because someone's a fighter,
does it mean it they're this aggressive,
atrocious human being.
An exact Frankie Edgar's one
of the greatest guys ever.
And probably the pound
for pound or forget,
wait,
toughest guy in the UFC?
He's a savage.
Yeah,
I mean gritty like the,
the,
the heart that that guy has and
the pace that he puts on you.
I mean,
he'd go,
I think that guy pays
for pace is like there's,
there's almost no one who could beat that.
There's almost no one who has a work ethic
like him in pain doesn't register the
same with him,
you know?
And,
and he's totally sane.
We've had some fires,
Nafta and that.
I don't think pain registered with you.
I don't think they were all there.
You know,
Frankie's a guy that
when he feels it hurt,
his heart's burning,
his lungs built,
burning,
he just teaches,
tells himself to go forward.
He just keeps going.
And the other thing I,
you know,
when you see a mountain public,
none of it's gone.
I mean,
he's still the same kid that'll go eat
like a bowl of pasta down to the local,
you know that the corner
store with everybody.
And that's,
I mean,
his whole community just loves that guy.
Yeah.
He's a great guy.
He is.
He's it.
He's a is a perfect example.
What you were saying,
like you'd think of a cage fighter,
especially a champion,
a championship level,
UFC fighter in this nicest
fucking guy you ever want to meet.
Yeah,
yeah.
There's a lot of those in this sport.
There's a lot of those guys in the
sport that defy the stereotypes.
And that's one of the things that
I love about the sport and the,
one of the reasons for that I think,
is that so many fighters,
they develop this understanding
of who they really are in the gym.
This you can't have,
you can have an unchecked ego
and be a basketball player.
You know,
you could really think of the fucking
greatest thing since sliced bread.
You're slammed Dunkin people because
you're not getting strangled every day.
You're not getting guys with a run,
a fresh guy in every five minutes and
they're all murderers and they're all just
on top of you,
smothering you need and you in the Dick,
you know you're not,
you're not getting that.
And that humility that you get from
training and tapping and losing and,
and getting it all beaten out of you.
Also the aggression that you expend in
the gym to just blow it all out of your
system.
You don't have any need
to get in fights outside.
And you know what I've noticed too,
it for me at least
personally helped me a lot.
When you go through this
really hard workouts,
you get on with this,
when it's over,
you get this moment of almost
euphoria where you gain perspective.
And,
and for me,
you know,
MMA fighting help me with a lot of demons
that I carried over that I never had
issues with them.
I in my personal life,
you know,
because I had fighting is
my outlet and you know,
you would finish these workouts or you'd
finish a fight and have the high of
winning a fight and it would give you
this perspective on your life and all of a
sudden
you have more of this,
this clear thought process to make
decisions and not rush decisions or see
things a little more clearly
and not get angry about x,
y,
or z because all of a sudden now you're
seeing them a little differently and you
get that when you're,
when you're exhausted.
Yeah,
yeah.
When you did,
you've expended all your
biological need for aggression,
which men,
you have to stoss throne.
You have a dick.
It works.
I mean,
this is a reason why people go to war.
All this stuff is a part of our genetics.
It's a part of our DNA.
And to expend it,
to just get it all out of your system
creates this balance and that balance
doesn't exist in a lot of people.
There's a lot of people out there that
have this unaddressed aggression inside
of them.
That's why I see people that
would never get into a fight.
Fuck you.
They're in their car,
they're fucking finger in
people and lay it on a horse.
I'm screaming.
It's like this is their release.
Like they don't have a real release.
And so since we're not living in a world,
we have to worry about barbarians running
over the hill with broad swords every
couple of weeks and you're not fighting
off Jaguars that are trying to kill your
babies and eat them.
You,
you,
we go through this life with all these
genetic needs that are never met.
You know?
I mean,
in many ways it,
it's just the downfall of our
culture that I've always said,
if you want to get rid of bullying,
teach people how to fight.
And a lot of people
think that that's like,
that's counterintuitive.
That's ridiculous.
Like you're going to make bullies
that know how to fight better.
The stronger blue's gonna Merge,
they're gonna kick everybody's ass.
I bet not.
I bet what you're going to do is you're
going to get people that have a greater
understanding of where this
aggression is coming from,
where their bullying is coming.
They will understand this is
a lot of it is insecurity.
Yes,
exactly.
It confidence is the number
one deterrent for bullies.
If bully bullies don't
bully confident kids,
they just don't.
If there's a possible threat that
that kid may hit you back or,
or may actually beat you,
they're not going to bully you.
And so I would talk to parents,
you know,
when I would teach kids,
um,
all the time that look,
you know,
learning to defend
yourself as a life skill.
It's a life skill to learn how to do that.
And it gives you,
it bleeds into other areas.
You know,
if you can push yourself
and get comfortable as in
these really uncomfortable
situations,
it's going to help you when you have
to go and maybe speak in front of the
class.
You know,
the first time you grapple
against somebody with all that Pr,
I mean you get the kids get nervous.
And when I would train,
I would train marines and the first
time it would make them grapple.
I had,
I had one that threw up right after.
There's so much pride.
They were afraid.
I got tapped out for all my other
classmates and it's such an Alpha Male,
you know,
play and,
and they got so nervous
a couple of weeks later.
I mean,
they're all in and they're
comfortable in that environment.
Maybe now public speaking comes more,
you know,
more naturally.
I mean they,
they get that fear and they get over it.
That bleeds into other areas of your life.
No doubt.
No.
I mean I've seen people in class
for the first time hyperventilating,
not like guys who've
done all sorts of sports,
but someone mounts him and all sudden
you see them like they can't fucking
breathe and you're like,
calm down dude.
Think of this as a game.
You're playing pool here,
you're playing basketball.
It's a game.
It's just,
it's game of arm bars and chokes.
You know,
you mess around with some of
these pro football players.
You know,
I've,
I've spent some time with Glaser
who trains a lot of those NFL guys.
You mess around with them and you start
dominating them and they start to panic.
Their egos are so big and
there's so you wait a minute,
why is this smaller guy than
me doing to me what he's doing?
And they begin to panic
and hyperventilate.
Just like you said.
Well it's also football players.
They never really go.
I mean they kind of go one on one,
but for these brief moments
and then whistles are blown,
flags are raised seconds.
You don't have to have that dig down deep
Frankie Edgar type heart and very few
of them do.
That's why it's so rare when you see a
guy like Hershel Walker subjects himself
to that shit in his late forties
what a fucking stud that guy is.
He's the scariest guy of all time,
48 years old,
smashing people in strike
force and you just go,
what?
I mean he probably would be like John
Jones if he started into his ego his young
days.
I mean the athleticism he had and
little his physique at that age,
you just push ups and sit ups.
I don't believe him.
I really don't.
Cause he says a lot of shit that's
just not scientifically possible.
Like he says,
he only eats a salad and one meal a day
that's a here to fucking be so skinny.
Well,
and I don't think he's the lion.
This is what I think.
He,
he has trauma induced,
um,
issues that he's had from football where
he has multiple personality disorder.
I mean,
he's spoken openly about those,
that he has more than one
person inside of his head.
And I know he's dealt with
this variety of different ways.
Therapy.
I,
I dunno if he's on medication,
I don't know what the deal is,
but if you have multiple personalities
and they're all living inside of your
head,
you might have one guy who just eats soup.
The fuck is another guy doing dead
lifts and eating fucking steak.
Okay.
That guy just doesn't talk to
you as a guy that you don't,
I mean,
I just don't,
I think it for sure.
He definitely did a lot of his exercises
just doing chin ups and pushups and
look,
if you do enough of them,
you can get pretty fucking swole.
Yeah.
There's a lot of guys who calisthenics
and build them a great body,
but you're getting all set.
I'm waiting on this really
serious scientific risk.
There may be one due
to eat soup inside it.
Yeah,
I think that's what it is.
I think.
Yeah,
but it's kind of crazy that he went into
MMA after this trauma induced multiple
personality disorder and I don't mean
not necessarily trauma physically,
but I think there's a lot of emotional
trauma and mental trauma as well.
But then again also a lifelong
career of getting hit in the end.
Yeah,
I mean the collisions that that
guy was a part of our on record,
you can watch them and
nobody rides for free.
They're all just fucking
crash into each other.
Super Athletes sprinting full blast
and fucking elbows and head to head
collisions and back before there
was this concussion protocol.
By the way,
where guys get them now
and they're out for weeks,
weeks,
you're back the next play back then,
what do you think is the number of
times where a person can be knocked out
before the athletic
commission steps in and says,
Hey,
this is enough?
Three,
three.
I think,
yeah,
my,
in my opinion,
I think at the athletic commissions
need to have a limit to where it,
once you,
if you get knocked out three times,
then you,
I think you should have to go in front
of a board to get your license in my
opinion and I'm sure that you know,
I haven't fully thought through this to
cover also for people started bashing me
for,
but look you and you can defend yourself.
Hey Look,
you know I've got three but
in this one I'm not out.
The ref stops this,
this is,
I was exhausted.
You could visually and then you have,
you know,
a panel at the organization's involved
to make a decision on whether you can be
commissioned again.
Do you think if this is the case and if
we're really going to be careful about
this,
do you think that fighter's should be
required to film training sessions so that
we can review so that we know
exactly like if you're sparring,
like you,
like you know how many times
guys been knocked out in the gym?
Yeah.
You know,
it'd be tough because they don't think
they have the capital to put in the right
kind of equipment.
I don't think so either.
But I mean if,
if you can go $40,000 for a fucking blood
test and they have 500 fighters that
are possibly subject to this,
if they make it too,
I mean most guys are just going to get
urine tested up until a certain point in
their career,
but then they get to a certain
point and you're going to,
you're going to have to go
through the full water testing.
If that's the case.
I mean,
how much does it cost
to put Gopros and gyms?
I mean,
how much does it cost to me,
there's ones that we have
now that are wifi enabled.
They can all be linked up
to a UFC database and the
UFC could be monitored or at
least storing all of the footage of,
you know,
all these gyms and then make
them sign contracts like saying,
look it,
you have to let us know if you're,
you're sustaining a concussion in the gym.
Like there's so many fights where
you see guys get knocked out,
you go,
well that doesn't even look right cause
you know that that guy got knocked out
in the gym a bunch of times.
Like um,
uh,
Travis Luder versus who's the
guy that veto for Marvin Eastman?
You ever remember that fight?
Marvin Eastman?
The word was that he got
knocked out not once,
but twice in camp leading up to
that fight once by Tito Ortiz,
he got hit with a knee
or something and once in,
during a take down he
got knocked out again.
So you're dealing with a guy
who had like six serious trauma.
And then Travis catches him with a punch,
which is a pretty decent punch,
but it catches him on the end of it.
And Marvin goes down,
like he got shot by a sniper rifle
Jitsu guy,
knocks out the striker out of nowhere.
Travis get hit hard.
He's a tough guy,
but it was just a weird Kao.
Oh
yeah.
Same thing happened.
Rashad Evans,
when he fought loaded Machida,
his last sparring session,
he got rocked bat,
I mean dropped and he got hit in the
same exact spot in the Cheetah would
eventually knock them out it by who?
Oh Gosh,
you that wasn't,
I don't think it was Jardeen.
I'm forgetting who,
but I remember,
I mean,
he could tell the story better than I,
well,
I've heard the Forrest Griffin leading
up to the Anderson Silva fight was
knocked out pretty badly too.
And the way he used to spar him.
That's right.
I used to,
you know,
I've sparred with him.
Um,
I sparred with him three days,
three days after I got back
from my second tour in Iraq.
I still had sand in my ears.
And Scott,
never Scott Adams.
The matchmaker if the WC.
Sure.
He was like,
Hey,
look,
I need to get you out here real quick.
I need you a photo shoot.
We're going to promote your fight,
your fight,
and in six weeks,
and I'd just,
all right,
I'll go to Vegas and bring my
wife sight see a little bit.
Nope.
We go straight to this
gym and I'm in a ring.
I had to borrow all this care
of no mouthpiece and he's like,
Hey,
I want you to spar this guy.
You need to get,
you know,
you need to get back in
the gym and get in shape.
I have no idea who the guy is.
I just know he's way bigger than me.
Turns out it's Roy Nelson
and the coach goes,
we're going to do five minute rounds.
Guys.
I had never done five minutes before.
I thought you only did that fights like,
that's crazy.
Nobody does five rounds.
Roy's hitting me with these
overhand rights and dude,
sand is still flying out of my ears.
You know?
I mean,
it was bad.
It was literally survival mode two times.
He almost knocked me.
I mean,
I went,
you like the rocky four up
and over the ropes in any,
threw me back in.
And then as soon as we finished there,
oh no,
no,
that's morning sparring here.
We're going to go to sparring
over at Randy couture's new gym.
So I'd,
I'd go down there and
it's Forrest Griffin.
I've got no mouth piece.
And again,
the kosher,
hey,
he's got no mouthpiece for,
she's in the military's
got free dental chips.
My teeth.
I mean,
but he used to get after it.
spark as hard as humanly possible.
Yeah.
Well look at him now.
Fucked up now because of it.
He,
he's his shoulder so bad.
I can't even brush his teeth.
And supposedly,
Holy Shit,
he's apparently he's right shoulder.
It's just like,
it's just not working.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's lost a lot of mass
when he looked at them.
Get all these,
had a lot of atrophy in his body.
I mean,
that guy fought fucking
hard and trained hard.
I mean,
Randy couture always said nobody
works harder than forest green.
Yeah.
But it's not always work hard.
Right.
It's work.
Smart guys are getting so
much smarter about that now.
I mean,
you look at like,
you know a guy like Anthony who's been,
you know,
he's been injured frequently,
but he's had to change his whole
training residence that he yes,
he gets himself,
they're healthy cowboy
Serone for as crazy as he is,
I think it was,
you know,
three fights ago.
He got dinged a little bit in practice.
He just eliminated sparring
and just stopped doing it.
That entire camp does a lot.
He does a lot less now
than people realize.
And in everybody he spars with is someone
hand selected and that understands,
and this is a wild man,
but he knows,
look,
I've,
things are changing.
Coaches are finally sort of relates
because back when I was fighting,
I mean none of these coaches
actually fought in the Onco,
right?
They were playing jazz at that point.
Nobody really knew the formula
to how to win in this state.
They acted like it,
but now they're finally starting to
learn and now we're starting to have guys
like Ludwig who grew up doing it and
now it's switched to the other side and
become a coach or seeing more guys
like that as well that understand,
you know what,
you got to hold these
guys back from themselves,
pulled them back,
train less,
less rounds them healthy to the fight
and there'll be way more productive.
Yeah,
it's really going to be interesting to
see what Duke roof is does with cm punk
because Duke Roufus is
essentially taking this guy once,
I read this article today where
they're interviewing Duke and he said,
you know,
I'm going to build this guy up from the,
from the ground up,
and he's not gonna spar
with anybody but me.
He's like,
he's got,
I'm going to have him spot with me
because I know that no one's going to hurt
him.
I'm,
I'm going to have give
them have total control,
but I'm gonna correct.
All of them is mistakes and it's a great
call to have a guy like Duke do that
because he is a master striker and a
master instructor and he couldn't get a
better coach for MMA for striking in MMA.
I put him right up there with Dwayne
and with for Rasa hobby and you know,
all the Matt Hume,
all the great guys.
But I think that a guy like that is like
an interesting sort of a test ground.
I mean,
first of all for the,
the public's just let me just credibility.
I mean you're,
you're talking about a guy who
was no amateur wrestling bouts,
no amateur karate belts,
no amateur kickboxing bowels,
no amateur boxing bouts,
no sumo,
nothing.
Just pro-wrestling.
Yep.
Which is,
you know,
entertainment.
So he's some sort of an athlete.
He looks like he's in good shape
down a little Jiu Jitsu training.
I mean,
I dunno how much she wears a white belt.
that ain't good.
Nope.
And he's,
he's getting there,
he's going to fight in the UFC and
a lot of people have issues with it.
I mean,
Jon Jones said he hopes
he gets knocked out,
you know,
and yeah,
I mean there's a lot of people that find
a Ben [inaudible] pissed is all hell
with a good right to be
and he's going to be coaching him now.
Yeah,
he absolutely right to be
Ben.
You know,
they will say Ben has and doesn't have
enough experience than the UFC hires is
zero and zero guy to
fight in the fucking UFC.
And against who though?
Another guy that they're going to handpick
for that zero and zero guy who also
doesn't belong in the UFC,
which is going to be really fascinating.
I mean,
how do they make it
compelling match for cm punk?
I think him by himself is that compelling?
He has such a draw and that people want
to see him come out of character who
this real guy is,
you know,
and they went,
hey,
is he,
you know,
and the WB,
he was a straight edge guy who was,
you know,
he had,
iron balls and blah blah blah blah blah.
Is He really that way?
You know,
does he show up in the octagon?
Is he scared?
Is he afraid to throw a punch?
Does he,
you know,
leaning back with his Chin held high?
Does he get demolished
or does he fight hard?
You know,
is if he tests positive for fucking EJBs
Twitter,
Twitter would absolutely just break.
It would be hilarious.
It would be Cosby ask,
oh
wait,
you know,
and he's an extremely intelligent
guy when you talk to me,
very bright guy and he's on this
journey and you can't fault him.
He just said I wanted to fight.
He can't fault him at did that.
The organization's going sign them and,
and,
and I,
I get,
you know,
where they're going with it as well.
But the good thing for him,
and when I spoke to him actually,
you know,
this past weekend,
there's no timeline from,
he can go train as long
as he wants to train.
And when his,
when Duke says he's ready,
that's when they get to match them up.
What I want to know is at what point
did they start getting impatient,
tapping their toes,
saying,
hey,
look,
it's been eight months.
Are you ready to fight yet or not?
UFC?
What's the point?
Yeah,
that's a very good point.
Yeah.
I mean,
as long as he does that,
that's a smart thing to do.
I'm,
I've always said that it,
Brock Lesnar did that.
He would have been one of the
greatest champions of all time.
If Brock Lesnar went to,
uh,
Matt Hume or for Rasa,
hobby type dude and had
someone just analyze his,
his physical movements and everything,
you're going to do everything half speed.
We're for four fucking months.
Yeah.
I want,
when I throw a kick,
I want your knee to come up
and I want you to check it.
When you throw a left hook,
I want to right leg kick just
to be coming out on instinct.
When someone throws a punch,
I want you instantly to roll with it.
I want to be it to be
a part of your anatomy.
I want to be a part of your DNA.
Drillers are killers and
it never became that guy.
He was just kind of brute force,
super athlete.
It's like,
it was like someone giving
you a corvette Zr one,
but never teaching you how to drive.
And he'd get on the fucking
highway and you've got a few moves,
you know how to turn left
and you know it turned right.
And for most cars it's going
to be enough to beat him.
But then you get this Cain Velasquez
cart that knows how to do everything and
you're like,
ah,
fuck dude,
that's an evil car.
It's an evil cards.
Scary car.
After John beat Daniel Cormier,
you know,
and he said he would fight
cane and a heartbeat.
Boy Did I get excited about that fight.
I'm excited about that fight.
As much as I'm excited about it.
Gustafson rematch or rumble?
Johnson fight almost.
It depends on what happens
in the Gustafson rumble.
Johnson fight.
If Gustafson knocks out rumble Johnson
or rumble Johnson knocks out Gustafson.
If one of those guys finishes the
other guy in a very definitive way,
then I want to see that fight.
Yeah.
But until that John versus came,
he be fucking crazy too.
You know how long canes
been out over a year?
Does he,
I mean you,
we expect because he was so dominant
that he comes back true to form,
but you got to wonder,
does he,
I mean,
that's it.
He's had a lot of injuries and,
and certainly,
you know,
Verdomme he,
he gets overlooked time and time again.
I mean,
I certainly did when
he fought Travis Brown,
I thought Travis Browne was going to
have a lot more success man for doom.
I mean,
he may,
he made him look,
he made them look mediocre.
How about the Double Jab?
Where the fuck did he developed a
fucking Lennox Lewis Style Double Jab?
I mean,
he look great standing up.
his standup has improved
a really dramatic fashion.
Knocking out Mark Hunt
with a fucking flying knee.
Like what?
Yeah,
I fell Cordero got a lot
of love from the past guys.
He's trained,
but honestly,
some of his best work has been
recently what he's done with VRE doom.
What he's done with Hofeld dos Anjos.
Yeah.
I mean he's,
he's starting to bring up,
um,
son of a gun I'm missing.
Um,
Darwish Peniel dark [inaudible] as well.
Who's,
who's undefeated in the UFC so
far has had some very good fights.
Who's,
who's a black belt,
he's a grappler that now is turned
striker and being successful.
He's starting produce guys that
shouldn't be good and really showing
some depth in the technique to not the,
the crazy shoe box style
people were accustomed to,
but a lot of traps,
trickery set up,
you know,
very technical it lots of volume striking
with a lot of depth to a different
looks,
different styles
and Codero you can't get a nicer guy.
And that's the other thing is that these,
these fires have this bond with him
because he's such a lovable guy.
So great.
They want to win for him a lot.
Like the Ray Longo thing.
Like they,
they love Ray Longo.
They want,
they want that guy.
Therefore then they want
to make that guy happened.
Hafael is just such a nice guy.
He's such a nice guy and you know,
it was a great fighter himself really
understands and really becoming a part of,
or because he's a part of shoot to
box the history of MMA mean he's like,
he's legacy.
Yeah,
yeah,
absolutely.
What were that comes from?
Imagine calling a fight and having Ray
Longo come in for a fight and grab a
headset.
I think Ray Longo and Matt Serra should
have their own fucking reality show.
I just,
those two guys cornering fighters.
It would be,
it would be absolutely incredible.
Absolutely.
They're hilarious.
And they're like my favorite
kind of east coast guys,
you know,
that that east coast sense of humor,
humble self deprecating.
And I mean they're,
they're,
they're great human me,
I spent a weekend Fort Hood with Matt
Serra during one of the fight for the
troops.
I mean,
you couldn't find a funnier guy.
the whole time Dane is texting him,
telling him how fattiness
and then we go to,
we go to,
who's the big puppet guy in Vegas?
Terry Fator,
we get Dana gets front row
tickets as Terry Fator show.
And so Sarah's texts and Dana,
look,
I may have put on some weight,
but I,
you know,
I sure it's held in asked
for tickets to a puppet show.
Dana,
you know what?
I'm 30 some years old.
I could have passed on.
I could've seen this by staying home.
My kids.
Thanks for nothing.
Yeah,
it's funny.
he's fucking hilarious.
They're funny guys,
man.
That east coast mentality that there's uh,
there's,
there's just a different sort of sense
of humor that comes out of long island.
This fucking guy over here.
Jesus Christ.
They're funny,
man.
Listen man,
we're out of time.
We did just did three hours.
Holy Shit.
You're the first ever
HD podcast we ever did.
Uh,
how many gigs is this going
to be too big for you stream.
We'll,
we'll see what this happens.
But you're the first one.
Ah,
listen man,
run for president.
Please.
You can run.
You can do it eventually.
Maybe one day if I get
pissed off at me ladies,
gentlemen,
I think you could win.
I'll get behind you.
I'm not going to be like a
vice president or anything,
but I'll be a
he on an Niu spoke lecture.
I got a whole bunch of people.
They've got to come to the cabinet.
Yeah,
I don't think you want
take your fucking cabinet.
Let me tell you some
stories to talk about.
Skeletons.
Both of us have some fucking graveyards.
Uh,
listen.
Thank you very much man.
And please do your own podcast.
You'd be fucking fantastic at it.
I appreciate everything,
Joe.
Thanks for that Brian.
Man,
you're awesome.
You're awesome at commentary.
You were a great fighter.
You're great dude.
You're very intelligent.
You're a great speaker.
You'd be awesome.
This,
I mean,
I,
I'm definitely looking
into do it and you know,
hey,
if some of the listeners
here and joining me,
you guys,
let me know if,
if you think it would be worth listening
to you and if you didn't keep your
fucking mouth shut.
All right.
Dirty bitches and Ray Longo to your house.
Uh,
Brian Stann on twitters,
s.
T.
A.
N.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for having me guys.
All right,
fuckers.
We'll see you soon.